Oh fuck yeah.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Oh fuck.
Yeah,
so we're doing this place on the 22nd and the 23rd we're working together two
nights in a row.
Bryan County.
That's what's happening.
Ladies and gentlemen,
key believed this.
I get to work with one of my best friends on the planet earth,
Brian motherfucking calendar,
September 22nd and 23rd 22nd will be at the Ice House.
I hate saying one of my best friends because I don't want to be mean to my other
best is how it is.
I'm kind of you
guys at the end of the day.
At the end of the day,
how do I fit in your fucking program?
My number three cock saga now I'm very easy to hang out with for you that it's
just,
it's no,
we're both retarded.
Yeah.
We speak each other's language.
That's the best part of it.
Yeah.
We understand the 23rd you guys,
Hong Kong,
Ventura and Ventura,
California.
Yeah.
We're doing two shows now.
We just added an eight o'clock to 10 it's not,
it's not for sale yet,
but it will be for sale soon and then eight o'clock and at 10 o'clock show and
Tuesday we're doing something.
Um,
that's like a showcase at the ice house.
Just me and Callen on Tuesday night,
the 22nd 22nd on the 23rd the 22nd ice has 23rd Hong Kong in two shows eight and
10 if we just had a hunting trip in with that,
ah,
it might be the perfect week.
Ah,
we need to go hunting again.
Yeah.
It's not even about the animals,
it's just an,
it's an opportunity for me to be a silly goose and have you captive five days.
Well,
one of our favorite trips was the one in Alaska,
which was the most miserable Rinella had a really fucking good point about that
trip.
He and he was talking about things that are fun.
He's like,
there's things that are fun while you're doing them and then they're not fun
afterwards,
but there's things that are not fun while you're doing them and they become
really fun after you've done it.
Such an interesting point.
Yeah.
It's one of his buddies has this scale of fun.
It's like,
and the cheapest easiest fund is like roller coaster rides,
but nobody looks back on a roller coaster where he goes,
man,
at the time it went down fucking rollercoaster,
man.
Yay.
We did that real look dude.
We went up,
we went down with all those other people strapped to our seat.
No,
no,
no.
You need,
you need an element of suffering.
You need to be shivering in the morning and wet.
And I think because they've done some studies on what happens when you're in
those situations,
you create anxiety actually creates oxytocin.
And oxytocin is a bonding chemical.
So when you're going through the shit,
when it's raining and you're cold and you're like,
fuck man,
this is going to sock.
We gotta go find a deer.
It's actually a bonding experience.
And what happens is when you think back on it,
like what,
what are you going to do when you're sitting there freezing in the rain?
You're going to make each other laugh.
It was just silliness.
You know?
What else are you gonna do?
And I think what with you and not,
yeah,
but you and I have a good attitude for that stuff.
We can both just accept the fact that we're in a bad environment.
There's some people that just can't accept it and they freak out.
Yeah,
those are the ones you can't bring it with you.
I can't bring those people with me,
but even those people,
I always submit that.
A lot of that is like how you've always approached bad situations.
Like how have you have you learned?
Well I would say it's also a factor,
a fact that they are thinking about the wrong things,
so they always say mental strength is more about what you choose not to think
about and shitty circumstances.
Like Tim Kennedy was telling a really funny story about when he was doing a
ranger because I asked him,
I said,
what drives you?
Like how do you,
how are you so tough?
What do you think it is?
They said,
I dunno man.
He said,
I was ranger training and the,
and it was so cold.
I was laying on the ground and we're winning for us,
simulate an ambush and I,
my my,
my Dick was hitting the like a woodpecker.
I was shivering.
My body was shivering like,
like that and some do just got up and went down the road and said,
I quit.
I give up,
I'm done.
And Tim is sitting there freezing and he goes,
that dude is so fucking smart.
He's so much smarter than I am.
Here I am in the shit.
And that guy is smart enough to be like,
fuck it,
I don't want to do this anymore.
And he was just,
he just says,
I was just too stubborn to quit.
Now I'm more impressed at Tim then I am with that depends on what the guy did.
If you left and started some global powerhouse of a company like Tesla motors or
something like that and went on to make $1 billion in the next two years,
I would say,
yeah,
that guy probably did the right thing.
That's why it's really important for our society to be structured in such a way
that you allow people to do what they're meant to do.
If you're in Russia,
the guy with the biggest guns and the biggest muscles,
that's the guy that runs everything.
But how much innovation comes out of Russia was the last time you bought a
Russian computer,
a Russian car or Russian,
anything.
It's a very good point.
Yeah,
good fighters.
They make good fighters and they're very tight hose,
very macho culture,
like aggressive men.
The hose,
a fantastic point.
They are on point.
And I was 17 and I had my experience with two of them in the Cosmos Hotel,
hopefully in Russia.
I sure did.
17 spent Lana and Christine at the money.
Uh Oh.
I didn't give them money,
but I did give him my Nike shoes and my blue jeans and my blue jeans because
there was a guy there.
So this is before we sorted out the Cold War,
1985 so it was still danger.
I was 1817 you barely could get over there,
right?
I mean you can get over there with,
they looked at you funny.
You got to government monitor.
Um,
the government monitoring.
They would bug your hotel room to make sure you weren't,
you know,
Kate,
uh,
at CIA or whatever.
So to just walk around in your hotel room and go,
Oh fuck yeah,
I'm calming,
cooling,
communism,
communist turns cod.
We fully look at trends all the time.
Gum,
look,
I'm going to come look,
he's come,
he had his gum there.
He'd come bathroom,
he'd come Boucle knee,
come television on bid,
we'll clean.
Not me is young.
He's 17.
His Dick never go down.
Oh,
was don't Mike Swick told me,
Mike Swick,
uh,
used to work for some government agency.
I forget what it was,
but I want to say secret service.
Um,
but they were in Moscow.
They discovered these listening devices that the Russians had placed in their
buildings and they were so sophisticated that they were powered by the movement
of the building.
Cause every move,
every building has subtle movement.
Like if you've ever been in a building that is in an earthquake,
it's a very weird feeling because you feel the building like rocking back and
forth and it's,
it's disconcerting.
You know,
it's like Whoa,
this thing fucking moves man.
But there's a constant moving and swaying with the wind and it's very minute and
sometimes you can feel it like it was a heavy storm,
but most of the time you can't hold.
The Russians had figured out how to make some piece of sound equipment power by
that.
So it had no external power source.
It was completely powered by the movement of the building and so the device
would turn on.
Wow.
So it's not,
he was walking,
it would turn out well.
So I don't know the specifics but I know that it was a very sophisticated device
that was powered by the movement of the building.
I think a lot of those are voice activated,
but you know like I used to have a voice activated tape recorder and at one
point I was trying to hook it up to the tank,
my isolation tank.
So they don't want them in the tank.
And I have a great idea.
I could just say it in a record it,
but I never just didn't use it because the idea is we're just common.
I like when you're in the tank,
the ideas are just coming at you like wet fish.
I know.
Try to catch them,
just try to hold onto one.
But they're,
they're really hard.
And that tank,
I tried to have no thoughts.
That's hard to do.
But this guy,
um,
uh,
you know,
swift,
that was when Swick was telling me these,
these guys,
whoever had set this equipment up in there,
they were using sophisticated equipment that the US government didn't even know
existed.
Wow.
Yeah.
It's always been a,
a technological race.
We were far ahead of them in Nicole war.
Just be sort of cut out,
switch.
Not with,
not with rocketry,
not with a,
the space program.
The space program.
Like there's,
you're always gonna have problems whenever there is a country where people don't
have the motivation to succeed and achieve because they don't get financially
rewarded or they're constrained by that sort of,
you know,
they have this sort of imperialistic,
Russian sort of economy.
It's a very different way of achieving success.
You achieve success if you get in with the right group of people and you have to
play the right politics and economy of influence.
You can't just be some fucking nomad,
some rogue investor who goes out and kicks ass.
It makes a lot of money.
They take those guys and they take their money and they locked him up in jail.
That's right.
I mean it's,
Putin has done that to many of these oligarch billionaire characters in these,
they made a lot of those guys made,
was going into politics and criticizing the government who didn't had sort of an
unwritten law that said,
you can make your money.
You got to pass a little something,
but you can make them money.
You start making noise about politics and that's what they did to,
what's his name?
The guy owned Yukos oil,
I think it's called the biggest oil.
And
they storm this plane and I think he's still in jail.
No,
just let him out.
They let them out.
But I think it's the same guy you're talking about.
Um,
it took all,
his was very famous case.
Took everything.
It took everything.
When you have a government like that,
when you don't have property rights,
when you don't have due process,
when you don't have objective law,
uh,
what happens is who in the world is going to work really hard to create a
company when the guy with the biggest guns can come along and take it again.
It is,
I'd love to sit down and ask him how he thinks that strategy makes any sense.
You know,
he's not thinking that it makes sense.
He's thinking that he can do it.
Yeah.
It's a very short sided thing that ironically makes your country way weaker.
It lowers your death,
your,
your life expectancy and everything rushes.
And one Rusch is a one crop economy oil and now that oil's at $40 a barrel when
it was at hundred,
they're having a major crisis.
Do you think that is part of the US strategy to fuck with them?
Absolutely not.
No,
absolutely not.
So you don't think the US government has any control whatsoever on the amount of
the price,
the price of oil?
Absolutely not.
It was in pot.
Russia's biggest problem is that their history has,
has either given rise to czars kings or a different kind of Tsar,
which is the communist dictator.
You know,
the Russians are a very industrious people and,
and you know,
you wonder what they would be capable of doing if they lived in a society where
the incentive structure rewarded you for your work and your ingenuity.
Right.
Unfortunately,
they have always lived under some kind of an autocracy,
some kind of oligarchies.
It's never been different.
I mean Putin is essentially a czar and he has his small group of people around
them.
Um,
so,
so I believe that it has nothing to do with the United States.
In fact,
it has everything to do with the philosophy.
That's not what I meant though.
Honestly.
I agree with you on all that.
But what I'm in is a price of oil.
Do you think it's manipulated to fuck with events?
I don't think it's possible.
Oh,
oils and a worldwide economy.
A commodity.
And so when it's traded on the worldwide economy commodity,
nobody's controlling oil.
Oil is out there and traded.
Right?
How's it going?
Do you know how it goes up and down?
Like when oil goes from fort at $40 a barrel,
a hundred dollars bell.
How's it do that?
I don't know the intricacies of that,
but I do know that one of the reasons it went from a hundred to $40 a barrel
was,
was fracking in this country.
And when we had our own access to massive oil shales.
Yeah,
that's a big deal.
It's incredible.
It's changed everything.
And when,
and all of a sudden we're no longer,
we're no longer dependent on Russian oil.
Uh,
other people aren't as dependent on rational.
They can buy our oil for cheaper or there's just a glut.
There's just more oil and when there's more oil being traded on the world stage,
the price will come down.
There is not a scarcity of oil.
I mean in fact,
oil now in 2015 I think is now.
Uh,
I mean the price of gas is ridiculously cheap because it's nobody expected
this kind of technology to create that much oil that quickly.
What does he know if fracking though seems like no matter what anybody says,
I mean there there's,
there's going to be debate.
Anytime there's anything controversial then anytime that there's any sort of
environmental risk was something like that.
It's hard to separate the facts from the noise.
Yes.
But it seems without a doubt that some areas are getting contaminated.
It seems without a doubt that some rivers and getting polluted so well systems
are getting fucked up.
That movie Gasland got criticized for some inaccuracies,
but they couldn't criticize all of it.
You know,
there's,
there's some undeniable aspects to fracking and also the potential aspects to
any kind of energy technology cause it,
the fact of the matter is civilization and feeding the civilization and energy
source is going to be at this point polluting.
Um,
and I think the way out of it is,
is you know,
a lot of people favor legislation and I think they might be a place for
legislation of course.
But I think what's really going to get us out of,
um,
that kind of an issue is technology is just create more incentives.
I don't care if it's through the government or you know,
government grants or private enterprise create incentives for smart people to
come up with clean technology.
And that's what we're doing.
You know,
that's kind of where,
where,
um,
you want to head,
you know,
it's not like there's going to be some sort of an instant solution for the
pollution of the atmosphere or the ocean.
But it seems like with people,
people are really fucking smart.
There's these giant leaps that they make every now and then and a lot of them
are due to pressure.
And then there's some real pressure where people worried about the environment
100% and there's going to be people way smarter than us.
They're going to figure some ways around it.
Like did you see about that 19 year old kid came up with a device to um,
clean all the,
a plastic out of the ocean?
No.
Yeah.
He wants some prize for it,
Jamie.
See if you could find that.
It's like some gigantic fucking skimmer that's going to go over the Pacific
garbage patch and it sucks the plastic out and I think it puts it to use.
See,
the thing about like plastic is if you could actually get it out of the ocean,
it's w it's valuable.
It has a value.
Well,
there's more.
What does that,
they did some things.
There's an island of plastic,
the size of the continental United States or something's not quite that big,
but it's like,
it's,
it's not necessarily an island to either,
like I've described it as an island and people have corrected me.
What it is is like soup.
Yes.
It's like there's the where the winning pieces.
Yeah.
They're very small.
And let's look at where the tide has.
You know there's,
there's areas where there's like a,
the currents,
they put things into like a,
a circulation and then it'll,
it'll all accumulate in this one area.
But it's like,
I think that any problem as a solution,
I actually really,
as I get older,
I,
I'm,
I'm way less cynical,
cynical.
I think the,
here it is right here,
ocean cleanup.
So this guy has figured out some way,
and um,
correct me if I'm wrong,
Jamie's,
this is the same one where there's a 19 year old kid who created this
damn,
I didn't see anything about this.
This might be a different thing because I never saw this part before.
We googled a,
the story from like 2013 when it was going home.
I just researched the new,
the new name to find them some updated stories on it.
Oh,
so this is the update.
Yeah.
This is their actual website.
Largest cleanup in history.
So they're going to create some gigantic,
huge machine.
It's probably gonna create a lot of jobs and they're going to suck all that
fucking plastic out of the ocean.
The real problem too is not just the plastic in the ocean,
but overfishing.
We kill a lot of fucking fish.
You know,
I wonder though,
if there's a way,
I mean they have hatcheries.
I wonder if there's a way for us to,
uh,
create hatcheries that release fish into the wild because we have hatcheries
that release a salmon.
We do it with salmon and we do a trout.
You know,
there's places where you fish for trout and the fish all come from hatcheries
and they stocked the fish.
Well,
the problem with is the dead zones,
the ecological dead zones in the bottom of the ocean where they turn the
trawlers with a drag for shellfish and stuff.
They drag these giant sort of clause that collect everything,
the size of semis.
And they just do that too.
And there are areas in the Atlantic that are massive dead zones.
There's some crazy amount like areas of size of western Europe that are
literally dead zones.
There's no,
there's no fucking plants growing down.
There was no oxygen.
Yeah.
The coral gets devastated.
But I had linguine with clams last night.
It was delicious.
I'm not going to go pick those fucking clowns.
I it was going to get me claims.
We'll figure it did it.
It's him looking at this same guy.
What a cool name.
Boyan slat.
Yeah.
He sounds like a wizard.
He's a Dutch entrepreneur.
Dutch high.
Highest Fuck guaranteed entrepreneur and inventor.
This kid.
This is the guy to get on the podcast now.
Before it becomes too big.
You need to find him.
Find him,
Jamie.
Make a note,
make a mental note.
Call Matt Stacks.
Find this young man will fly him out from Holland.
Tell him that we have,
we'd let him know.
He's only 19.
We could corrupt him.
Take them around.
Brian.
Red Bands.
Girls.
Exactly.
Spring.
That's Kryptonite for any team.
Just dirty places.
Yeah.
We had Alex Honnold on who is this?
Uh,
like one of the best free climbers can the world.
Yeah.
He is the complete name and he does it without ropes.
Yeah,
he does.
He does it with ropes first to map out his course.
Obviously you have to make sure that you can do it without ropes,
so you've got to do it with ropes first,
but then he just makes a decision,
knows what he can do and what he can't do.
Anyway,
he was like,
like real mellow and like steady until Brian brought up girls and porn stars and
you know,
it's just like what really?
Cause we they're inviting them to or him.
We were inviting him to go to Vegas.
There was a UFC in Vegas and we were doing a show out there and the guy's eyes
lit up like,
yeah,
it's funny.
It's just like you're not getting any pussy on that mountain.
I see it.
It's like the most plus the script,
Mac comedy.
A lot of these guys or women that can change your whole life.
What's that man's name again?
That young young fellow.
Bryant.
Buoyant,
buoyant slot.
Boyan slat guarantee you.
There's some girls out there that are reading the same thing,
especially dirty girls.
Listen to this podcast.
They're going to find him.
They want to get it finance.
The young Dutch suck money out of his Dick.
He's probably super tall girls.
Super Tall,
thin.
It doesn't matter if he is,
but he's actually the tos.
Men in Europe buy you a belly,
just suck it out of his Dick.
Then you get who could literally suck a Bentley out of his deck.
You just have to suck hard enough and just gently work the ball.
He just started crying into his pocket.
Yes.
Just be magical to him.
Be a magical nymph who came out of nowhere.
Just came out of the woods and get a get a trap phone.
Right.
All those guys that are sending you Dick Pictures,
don't give that number two.
What's the name again?
Boyan don't give it to black.
It's kind of funny that it is something that involves water and he's kind of
buoyant.
Yeah.
You know Boyan yeah,
that's all we need man.
Put One,
one girl,
one girl with a fucking an iPhone with no contacts on.
She's only getting messages from extort him for money.
Hi there.
Was she at?
Let's leave that phone laying around.
Never has to worry about getting in trouble cause it just dicks and vibrating
decks,
man.
Get some Russian gow some Russian Gal that maybe you met when you were 17 it's
still your sneaker,
so get her,
get her to find Boyan.
I Bet Putin Putin with fucking send his his attackers,
he's probably got a little train Parana women he's trained over guarantee.
Does all bang everybody in the fucking cabinet or whatever they have parlor.
There's a lot of fucking in the parliament.
Them is fucking with masks.
Well that's one of the reasons why star wars are so ridiculous,
okay?
Because Darth Vader had no motivation.
Darth Vader wasn't getting any pussy,
okay?
He was just being evil.
There was no money.
He wasn't like rolling around in money.
Domination has a right for what?
For what?
To wear that stupid mask.
Come on.
What are you going to do?
You can't even exist without that stupid helmet on and you're going to dominate
the universe and then what you,
when you're already winning and winning where you around,
you could choke them without even using your hands.
You can fake choke him from a distance and kill him.
What do you want?
But you wonder about people like gang is kind of what motivated him.
It was a plus.
He had bullies.
Hey,
do you know how much puts you that guy?
100 a male.
China,
Chinese men aged directly.
Yes.
Directly related to [inaudible].
He changed the fucking ecosystem.
It's crazy,
dude.
There's,
there was a New York Times article that said that he killed so many people,
something around 10% of the world's population died while he was alive.
Directly because of his decisions.
Yeah.
It was so different.
Biggest asshole on the planet or a great guy who was misunderstood.
It was killing a lot of assholes,
I think.
I bet everybody back then was an asshole dealing with 1200 and fucking kill 'em
all.
What do they know what Dan Carlin says?
You have to wonder what the strength of his nature was to wake up and say,
I want the world.
I want that,
which I can't even see.
He got a scouting guy,
came back and said,
look,
there are people with blond hair and blue eyes and what in what was Russia?
And they said,
we should go get those too.
And he was like,
all right,
let's go take them over to,
well,
not only that,
they were willing to go through so much hardship they,
they crossed into Moscow in the winter.
Yes.
Because there was no Samara,
she area that you could only cross through in the winter when it was frozen
solid.
But they,
no one ever thought that anybody would do that because it was so harsh.
The climate so harsh,
the Mongols didn't give a fuck.
They never wash their clothes.
They ate rats,
they ate each other.
Occasionally they'd run out of food.
There's,
there's,
that's disputed apparently according to drank coffee drink their,
uh,
their mare's milk and blood.
Yeah.
They would say cut their horses and then fill their,
uh,
their class with horse and mares blood.
And that's what they would survive on for days at a time.
Yeah.
They were just so fucking crazy.
Life in the Gobi desert on that,
on the step was already so insanely harsh,
insanely hard.
Sure.
Primarily a carnivore and the way they would hunt and catch birds and catch,
you know,
the deer and the whatever was there with their horses.
It was just a very harsh,
harsh way to live.
Well,
there's a reality to people that you could always take more,
you know,
most of the time,
up until the point where it kills you,
you could take more.
You know,
I was watching Rinella media the other day.
He had an episode on,
I don't want to say the name wrong,
Nan Nan Novak,
Nanu Vac island outside of a Alaska.
You can get to it when the fucking ocean freezes.
You can walk.
They're not doing that hunting trip.
They take,
they take jet skis across the frozen ocean,
Dan.
Okay.
And these people are out there and they hunt for this thing called a Muskox,
which has this enormous beast of an animal,
which I may go hunting in Greenland with Cam Haynes,
who might do an archery muskox hunt because apparently you can hunt them in the
dry green.
You don't have to be an asshole and be out there in the middle of the night.
Thomas died,
died hunting from muskox.
They taste delicious.
They taste like ribeye steak.
It's like it's just incredibly delicious fat,
big fat animal because they're just constantly eating to try to keep fat on,
to keep them warm.
And they're,
they're ridiculously cool looking and there's a lot of them.
So they're like,
yeah.
And in Greenland apparently there are.
Wow.
And will they thrive so you can go hunting for them in the grass where it's not
that exactly where you're doing it in the Arctic,
if you're doing it in Alaska,
you're hunting forum on these frozen Tundras.
It's crazy to watch Sam shirt and was telling me that they went to rescue.
I think they were hunting and Muskox uh,
but they went to rescue these guys who had been out on a hunt and they were
already,
they were so cold.
They were already dying of,
of frostbite,
hypothermia.
And they,
what they got there,
they were taking all their clothes off because what happens,
you know,
the blood rushes to your,
yeah,
you think you're burning.
They say wait a die.
Meanwhile,
you're going to go to the cryogenic chamber after this today.
Yes.
First Time Bring
Down my inflammation.
You got it everywhere.
Guarantee everybody does.
You're gonna feel like 1 million bucks to kind of immortal,
neoprene,
Afrin,
your brain produces this incredible anti-inflammatory and antidepressant.
Really.
You got to feel great.
I'm going to come out hug and I'll come alimony.
Muskox yeah.
Oh,
so this environment where these people lived,
I was like,
this is an incredible,
like the,
the,
the village was less than 200 people and you know,
it's just nothing but white.
You look around,
it's just frozen everything.
The ground is flat and white and goes on for as far as the eye can see.
And these people live in there,
man,
and they had the little kids and their kids were living there and they were all
bundled up except their faces.
They're like,
what's,
you know?
Ronell was like,
what's your favorite food?
He's like,
I like to eat,
seal the seal and Walrus.
Walrus is my favorite food.
So hearing walrus falling,
staying alive with,
if life started in east Africa,
there were some people that have just kept moot walking north.
Fuck Spain and the sunshine and the grass.
I don't want that now.
It's going where it's icy and it gets dark at noon.
Yeah,
this is home.
They didn't know any better man.
They didn't know where they were going.
I mean,
a lot of this,
when this happened,
people had a rudimentary understanding of navigation.
They just went in search of food and kept going and stay together and then wound
up here.
I mean,
nobody would have gone across the fucking Bering strait if they knew.
Right.
They just kept going.
Really?
Everybody should have stayed in Africa.
Yeah.
Although the Fertile Crescent,
it was even where you want to be.
Like Iraq or a number started cause you could have,
you had grasses that crew like barley and millet and wheat and it was easy just
the way and you could domesticate animals.
Well you know,
that's when they first started important coffee.
That's why the column era,
Becca,
Arabic Arabica beans.
Yeah.
It all came from Ethiopia.
All of us are that a fascinating gentleman on my podcast.
Um,
what's his name?
Peter.
I'm trying to figure his,
the last name.
Italian find it.
Um,
he was out a coffee guy,
an expert,
a real coffee expert and a really cool guy.
And uh,
he ran down the history.
What does his name Peter Juliano Juliano I've heard,
and tell me if this is right.
The Myth I heard was that Ethiopian goat farmers were watching their goats eat
these berries and they got,
they would get a pep in their step and have more energy when they were done
eating the berries.
Oh,
that's interesting.
Then the shepherds were like,
well,
if they eat and maybe I'll eat him and it makes sense.
Yeah.
And based on their other types of cooking the way you would,
you know,
Cook something.
They decided let's try to roast these beans and see what happens.
That makes sense.
I wonder,
I wonder if that's the case.
You know,
that was an issue with um,
uh,
that's how they figured out the cordyceps mushroom to cordyceps mushrooms,
high altitude hurting populations.
They're watching the animals eat these mushrooms and their animals would have
like more energy and you're like,
Huh,
what the fuck's going on here?
And they figured out that it helps an oxygen utilization.
That was before like the Chinese Olympic teams started using them.
Wow.
Yeah,
it's cool.
And you know,
you get animals to a try out food for you see if they die.
But the problem is like this some shit that they can't eat that we can eat for
the most part though,
they say that,
that uh,
like with dogs and they,
if the dogs eat onions,
it makes him anemic and stuff.
But for the most part they say if a birds eating it,
I've heard this,
I dunno,
you can eat it,
you can eat it.
Say if an animal's eating it,
but then again,
I think birds eat certain berries.
I mean there are certain berries and mushrooms you can eat.
You eat like half a mushroom and you're dead.
Yeah.
There's certain mushrooms that look real similar to psychedelic mushrooms.
And if you eat them,
you have like instant liver toxicity.
Like you might have to get a liver transplant,
you're going to die.
How fucked is that man?
You know,
there was an old lady,
um,
well not just one.
I think there was several people that died in a nursing home because this old
guy or old Gal,
I forget which one it was,
um,
went out in search of mushrooms and brought back with some mushrooms and cooked
it for everyone in the nursing home and they fucking die.
Well,
the,
you know,
the Oleander is super poisonous and I heard,
and it is only in blander is you see it,
it's like a nondescript kind of Bush with,
you know,
big kind of long cylindrical leaves.
And,
uh,
these guys used an oleander branch to cook their lamb.
These tourists,
they ran an oleander match and whatever,
whatever happened,
the PSAP got in the meat and they fucking died.
And then they had this really expensive a race horse.
And I don't remember where this,
this,
you know,
was,
you know how those resources are $100 million.
Like somehow that race was eight.
A couple of oleander leaves and died.
John Taylor,
why did you have oleander near the,
the horses stable.
Let's see a picture of oleander.
Jamie,
I need you to know that this stuff is,
that leaves fucking toxic.
That's tough right there.
I believe so.
So pretty.
Yeah,
it is.
Isn't it weird that like a lot of really pretty things are fucking terrible for
you,
Huh?
What girls?
You could lose your house.
The guys that like are like not used to really hot girls and you see it coming
when the guys who didn't get those girls in the high school and college and then
they,
then what happens is they get famous and they're 38 40 and they're kind of Dorky
or release.
Same as Nate date.
That trophy wife.
Well or they meet a girl and a strip club or whatever it is.
You've gotta be careful.
I was at this,
uh,
steak house the other night in Beverly Hills,
like guess very swank place.
Oh,
needed names,
sorry.
Very swank establishment.
But I was astonished by the number of disgusting men with attractive women.
I was like,
this is a fascinating,
like this guy.
I hope he can play a mean set of drums or fucking belt out a great tune or
something.
I mean,
how did he get her?
Like,
what's going on here?
Just really,
really rich guys in Beverly Hills especially that is where the oldest profession
in the world is rampant.
Just prostitution.
It's a different kind of prostitution
cause it's legal.
All you're just,
you're just professional girlfriends and wives for like really ugly dude.
Keep mad.
I buy her Scott.
I just got an apartment.
She's got a house.
I just got out the car.
Um,
another thing we found fascinating was the amount of Arab license plates,
Saudi Arabian plates,
they fly their fucking supercars over here.
There was a,
um,
a Bugatti VA Ron,
which is a one point something million dollar car,
this insane car and the palace plate.
It said something palace,
cause I was with a friend who's Persian and he reads Arabic and he said it said
palace.
And then the number plate was like 222,222 like that was the plate was all twos
and it said palace and it was just fucking,
I don't know,
I'm like one point something million dollar car.
Oh you like cars right now.
And I'm like those,
what is that car?
What is the,
well here's the problem with those cars.
I mean they're incredible pieces of technology.
I mean they're,
they're undeniable.
The speed,
the power,
the opulence,
the interior is gorgeous and beautiful and it,
and like,
it's one of those things at Floyd Mayweather drives around in,
but what I like is I like cars that are tactile.
I don't even necessarily like new cars.
I like,
like I'm missing something that can really drive oh yeah.
Moving towards like older and older cars.
Like,
even my Porsche is the newest car that I have.
That's a 2007 and I,
that's the last year that they made the gt three or the last model that they
made,
the gt three Rs.
The way mine is,
it doesn't have any,
uh,
like there's no stability control.
There's some traction control,
limited amount of traction control.
That's,
it's a race car and you could shut that off and you're on your own.
You just have this 520 pound horsepower ridiculously light car that you feel
everything you're telling me it only weighs 520 pounds.
No,
no,
520 horsepower.
Okay.
It's less than 3000 pounds,
but somewhere around 3000 pounds.
But what I'm interested in honestly,
is like 1970s cars,
like 1970 Porsche.
That's 2000 pounds.
Like a thousand pounds less and less powerful.
But you feel everything.
No power steering.
You feel the fucking bumps of the car,
you feel the road,
you feel that like literally you feel in your ass right word for them.
You feel when the car's rear end is breaking loose?
If you're,
when the tires are losing traction,
you sliding a little bit.
That's fun.
Yeah.
Like all this other shit,
like it's physical,
they're all computers is like,
whoa.
Like I drove a Nissan Gtr.
Do you know one of those are now it's just incredibly technologically
sophisticated rocket ship that Nissan's built.
It's almost like a,
a proof of concept vehicle.
Like the almost like they lose money on it.
It's a flagship vehicle and it's so fucking unbelievably ridiculously competent
and fast.
That car right there,
it goes zero to 60 in less than three seconds.
It's pretty understated.
It's not like,
well it's,
it's everything's functional.
That car as it's not about like,
I think it looks cool because it looks like a spaceship.
Yeah.
But everything about it is about aerodynamics and about keeping the body pinned
to the ground.
It's heavy.
It's about 3,900 pounds.
So it was like 900 pounds more than my car is.
And it's four wheel drive,
which like race car drivers traditionally like a rear wheel drive car because
they liked the feel that it's pushing instead of pulling,
they liked to the control that you get because you can kind of steer with the
throttle if you know as you're going into a turn is a thing called oversteer,
right?
So if you're going into a turn and uh,
as you're going into a turn,
you can hit the gas and your ass and we'll kick out and it'll change the angle
over entry into the turn.
You got to know how to do it just right.
You have to have this field.
So you've got to know like,
like it's more fun than anything cause really the correct line if you're on a
race course is to have no,
no ass and kickout like you want it,
you want everything to be glued.
Every time you're asking kicks out,
if you're racing,
you're going to lose seconds.
But for fun,
like guys who love like those kind of,
uh,
like like a nine,
11,
like in 1979,
11.
One of the things that they like about it is the asset.
And we'll kick Alec.
This has got Chris Harris.
I've had him in here as well.
A tail happy that it's,
yeah,
it's,
it's oversteer.
Chris Harris is a very famous uh,
automotive journalist from the,
uh,
UK and he takes it to the next level.
He likes to power slide around corners.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
I,
well,
watching him do it,
he's an artist at it and he's going around corners in these cars.
Every car he reviews he takes and he power slides like everywhere.
It's just,
just power sliding these fucking things like go meaning like the Chris Harris
kind of gt three Rs,
2016 gt three Rs.
He's literally going sideways around corners with a 500 horsepower,
$200,000 Porsche that they let him borrow.
That's so they let him borrow this car,
just beating the fuck out of it everywhere he goes.
No,
that's a,
that's an old one.
No,
no,
look up.
That's,
that's my year.
That's like a 2007 2016 gt three go down there.
So it says gt three Rs accelerations.
Empower slide c.
Okay.
Yeah.
You could see it probably were there you,
you won't see Chris Harris do it,
but you'll see a car that does it.
And the idea is that these guys go around these fucking corners and they go
around these corners using the ass end of the car.
Like using,
yeah,
no,
let me see if they do it later.
Okay.
Um,
but anyway,
it's just fun.
Cool.
Look,
go Chris Harris,
gt three Rs,
2016 Gulu that
and then you'll see,
huh?
Chris Harrison cars top one,
top one.
Yeah.
Now like three quarters of the way in there and you'll see him on a race track
with it even further air.
Here's this crazy fucker.
Like this guy's a mad man and he just knows how to drive a this
great.
See right there.
He's just leaving a little bit of rubber.
He's just trying to go fast as fast as he can.
See how he's taking these lines,
the outside to the inside.
It's all about trying to go around corners in a straight a line as possible so
that you have as little pressure on the tires,
uh,
sideways as possible.
And it's all about like choosing the correct line to go around the corners.
Most officially it would be more macho,
but see,
no,
he's not.
He's a thug and he's not in real life though.
But here it looks,
see all that rubber look he's going sideways around the corner,
that damn.
Give some volumes so he can hear that cause he's just having a great fucking
dog.
We wanted me to hear it.
We don't have our heads up.
Just mega lovely little sleepy feeling on the end,
Slippy feeling that guy fucking loves cars.
See that.
Just don't want me to range really thumps you out.
Definitely has more traction.
If you have a car and you're selling it,
you want a motherfucker like this review in it.
This guy loves cars,
he loves him and he's smart as shit.
Man really understands automobiles.
It's funny how you have when it,
when you told her that she sounded really,
really smile.
A yeah man.
That's why they sell fucking mops with that voice.
You want this mop,
this mop,
mop,
and the world's most sophisticated in that mock.
You're going to bass,
right?
It's simulated to Musk ox and Scott.
Really fantastic.
Something ability.
So you don't,
you don't find a thrill in this sort of,
uh,
automotive automotive fucker.
There's nothing about this is appealing to you.
If you got power slot.
Bernard Hopkins is talking about how he sets up his jab.
That's interesting to me.
How does this not interesting to you?
I feel I'm missing never been interested in cars.
If you've got a broken gene or something wrong with you,
you're not even American.
I know you were born out of the country.
That's what it is.
Well,
no,
but how the coach was born.
Remember other countries like what country though?
Where do you want to?
Philippines.
That's the thing.
Philippines not known yet.
Car.
I bet you get crazy when you see a scooter.
I bet if you see like one of those I do.
I go crazy when I see a moped and I see a Rick Shaw.
Um,
hi.
Hi.
You give him a raw coconut,
he loses his fucking mind.
Yeah.
I just never a,
maybe that's what it is.
I was in a Bruce Lee.
I was always in the physical things like that.
Although grace card drives race,
car driving a support.
Absolutely.
I think so.
Right?
Percent.
It seems like,
I mean it's,
you're managing your body as well as managing an automobile.
You without a doubt the one's gotta be a sport.
Well,
it's all,
it's all your own movements.
Your movements are dictating the movements of the car,
your movements of the wheel.
Especially in the old days when they would actually shift with the clutch.
Now everything's
paddle shifters.
Why do you think Formula One is so huge in Europe and everywhere else and not at
all in the United States?
Be standing with God,
our own Nascar up in this,
that big,
I guess it is huge.
If you ever go to like the south,
do you ever go to the radio and like Georgia and they start talking about Nascar
and you're like,
what?
Yeah.
You literally look,
Dale did last weekend,
low t boy.
Let me tell you what,
that guy knows how to drive a car.
I'll tell you what a Gar,
oh,
he's driving a car.
Who's Dale?
We like?
You ain't his late.
You didn't see the Nascar is Nascar is Nascar.
I'm not as technical,
isn't it?
Kind of like,
all I know is they let chicks do it.
No,
so sold.
They let girls do it and and you know something.
You know something's up with that score.
I could probably do it better all day.
I can be and have a prenup.
I they compete with men think,
well they claim to be there.
I think that Danica Patrick Chick,
she wins.
It's downright on America,
but she's tough as shit,
man.
It's probably the Ronda Rousey of a race car driving.
He knows how to do it.
Easy on the eyes too.
Not a bad looking Gal.
Not at all.
That's a tough fucking sport though,
for sure.
It's,
it's,
you got to maintain your nerves.
You got to figure out when hit the gas,
when he hit the brakes,
he got to know when to make your move and your piloting that fucking car.
It's not automated in any way,
shape or form.
It's all up to you to decide how to bust them all.
It's super dangerous.
And your reaction time means a lot,
right?
Did they have a clutch?
Does Nascar have a clutch?
Are there those things?
Automatics?
I think they got clutches.
I would hope so.
Being American at all.
Being American.
I don't know.
They make those mother fuckers shift their own gears like Tom Cruise and days.
I've done dark nice car like power shifting.
Maybe they don't have a clutch.
I don't know.
Are gonna get mad?
What happened to America?
What did we do with the left pedal?
We need the left pedal.
Bring back the left pedal.
Some bitches.
You uh,
you need to drive a fucking real car,
man.
I need,
you need to go.
Go get yourself a Mustang.
Gt three 50.
When they come out,
gas man,
shut the fuck I need.
Says Jazz.
What do you,
what do you,
what do you do?
You busy every minute of every day.
You can't stop at a gas station and it put the fucking thing in the slot and go
get yourself over that.
Both hands.
I can't do it's warmed.
No.
Yes.
Swarmed.
Holy Shit.
Stations.
I can't.
The kid is the kid.
Hey man,
Jesus.
What does that a Volkswagen Passat instead of a diesel.
I drove it to get to Tesla.
What do you think?
Great car.
I love it.
Yeah,
I would buy one.
The only thing I wouldn't buy it for is if like you ever have to take your
family out of the state.
Fucking shit hits the fan.
Good luck.
Oh,
I got another car for that and we need another car for that.
I've got to tell you that I Highland there for that.
But that's a good move.
Yeah,
those are great.
That's a great car.
Yeah.
I mean for a car around town,
it's awesome.
And you know,
the other thing is if you install solar your house,
I
do get fucking power that thing easily with solar panels.
Ted,
that's pretty interesting.
I mean you,
I mean obviously it costs money for the batteries and the setup and the
maintenance and all that jazz,
but at the end of the day,
um,
once the money is spent on setting it up and the operating costs are fairly
minimal in comparison to what it would cost to get electricity off the grid,
you can be totally off the grid if you choose to be.
And you can also power your fucking car with all this.
And if the grid goes down,
you can keep your power.
Like there's ways to set that up.
I didn't,
what's interesting is when you put solar panels in your house,
which I did just,
just try getting,
it'll take you the electric company.
It's been three months now and they still haven't converted us.
They haven't,
they just take their sweet time.
What do you mean?
The [inaudible]?
Yes.
They have not yet given us the,
okay.
It's what's the,
They've got to just give you the,
okay.
They have to give you some kind of a form.
So are you still spending money on electricity?
Siam but as the electricity being generated by solar or by,
by them still,
they will not let us say we're in ourselves or anything over it.
What the fuck is living in a permit?
And guess who has to do that?
Some bureaucrat and the electric company.
Whoa.
So there's no dragging their heels.
They're trying to keep people from going solar.
Yes.
You sure about that?
Yup.
They sure about the oil price is two minutes.
Come on.
Yeah,
I know these things.
Government,
tinfoil conspiracy.
Hi.
Hi Man.
One of the main things,
I feel like there's gotta be some way.
Well look man,
here's how I feel like,
like as far as conspiracies concern,
I believe more in ignorance.
So I,
you know,
government is my buddy who works,
I just was at his wedding and he said,
he goes,
if you think the government's really efficient and he's talking about
intelligence or any of that stuff,
because I've been in the inner circle,
I said,
it's not,
you just have to work for the government.
And No,
yes,
we do some cool stuff.
But this,
a lot of it's just not as organized.
I'm sure,
and I was thinking about this,
like people tease me for being a history guy.
I'm not,
not not like Dan Carlin,
but I tried it,
you know,
read my history.
I was thinking about this,
you know,
this new Harvard study just came out and it said that 170,000,
170,000 veterans from our recent wars in Afghanistan and Iraq starting in 2003,
we have 170,000 people that are 70% or more disabled that is probably going to
cost over their lifetime than the American economy.
$6 trillion to care for those people,
which you can,
which according to the study you could parse out to be 75 grand of,
uh,
an American family.
Forget the cost.
Think about 170,000 people that are 70% or more disabled.
These are,
these are veterans.
These are people that answered the call and they're all fucked up.
And I was thinking about how if the more you read about this war and how we got
into it,
a lot of it was because we didn't know the history of that country.
Um,
and a lot of it was because we didn't know the history of the entire region and
would make that argument.
And my point is that it's really easy for all of us as voters.
It's to go about life without doing the right investigation.
So when you vote for somebody and you vote for a policy,
most of us vote along party lines because our team has over here because we're
not a liberal or we're not a conservative,
we're not a Republican,
not a democrat.
Instead of looking at the world as,
wait a minute,
we're going to go into Iraq.
Hmm.
That's an interesting thing,
man.
How much do we know about the history?
How much do we know about how the country is structured at how much do we know
about what's going to happen?
We'd when we'd destabilize that regime and when most of Congress didn't know the
difference between Sunni and Shia,
which is so important in the eastern politics that schism and we're voting in
these policies and I think that that we could have avoided some major tragedy.
I don't know why,
you know,
I'm just saying that,
that the more you know,
the less likely you are to make these major fucking,
he's,
you know what's fucked too.
Cause you're kind of damned if you do and you're damned if you don't when it
comes to Iraq.
Because if you think about leaving that guy there,
Saddam Hussein was a fucking piece of shit.
He will epic proportions and his children were absolute serial killers.
The his children.
There is a story about him and his children from,
I forget what magazine it was,
maybe like Esquire or something like that for back in the day,
Gq something.
Um,
but it was a terrifying story of all the atrocities that his sons have
committed.
Include them taking women on their wedding day as they're being married,
kidnapping them,
raping them,
and then feeding them to dogs.
Yeah,
it would if feeding the husband and dogs to do all kinds of statistic things,
but think about,
think about the untold misery that that entire region now over the past 15 years
or actually 13 years has,
has dealt with.
Think about the how many children and how many people think about the Yazidi
women sold off into the slavery by these the Isol assholes and the spawning of
ISO would have been the case.
Come up with a standardized name.
I'm tired of hearing I sill,
I says Islamic Cis Sang.
Just say Islamic state,
the space station.
There's too many different,
there are too many fucking isol.
Yeah.
What the fuck?
You're the first guy I've ever heard say Isol I've seen it written.
I'm like,
what is this?
You know I said it cause it sounds fast.
Fancy cars.
I don't know what,
Oh,
it's like when John Cutler Mellencamp turned into John Mellencamp remember?
Yeah.
The fuck you.
He made a stand.
He used to be John Cougar.
Mellencamp no,
he was John Mellencamp,
right?
No,
he was John Cougar first.
he was John Cougar.
Mellencamp wasn't he then it changed the first time he came out of want to say
he was John Cougar and then he became John Cougar mill.
His real name's John Mellencamp obviously.
Yeah,
but it'd be conditionally.
Oh no,
he didn't give his name.
He didn't give himself the name.
Cougar.
No,
no,
no.
The,
I believe that the record company did here.
That's terrible.
A duty a Jag.
Um,
John titled Miami
in Australia.
What?
1979.
It's called Miami in Australia.
They call his album Miami or he's Miami,
but wait,
John Cougar,
I was talking to the record company to go,
fuck.
That's a test of the album is called Miami.
If you're in Australia,
Australia is like,
yeah,
we're not going to buy it.
My price thing with John Coogan just junk.
Ooga it's not good enough,
mate.
We need something spicy.
I want you to name and after Miami changing in a until path.
We've seen guests from Miami,
they have big offices.
We like that.
Call it Miami.
Well Sal,
Mo,
terrible Australian accent.
So I did my best.
I just don't want,
I want,
I only have a few Australian friends and you know,
hello.
Hi John.
Of the shrimp on the Barbie.
Oh,
by the way,
my second show for Melbourne is almost sold out,
so you've got to fluoro thinking about going.
You fucks.
You better.
Act first one.
Sold out,
selling out over oceans.
Very close to selling out.
Nice.
I haven't been in Melbourne.
Never.
I'm so excited.
It's supposed to be like the San Francisco of Australia,
like sophisticated and a very,
uh,
just rich and culture.
They supposedly have an amazing food scene.
Like the food in Melbourne is supposed to be spectacular.
I keep hearing that.
Saw an Anthony Bourdain episode about it too.
We went there and sampled some of the quasi,
I've not watched enough of Anthony Bordain I used as best.
I love the shit out of that dude.
He's my boyfriend.
You love him?
He's great.
Yeah,
he's 58 years old.
The guy gets into Jujitsu,
just turns his blue belt.
It's fantastic.
He's a junkie.
When he was younger,
like almost overdosed and died,
smoked cigarettes until he had a kid.
Had the kids said,
you know what,
I've got to quit smoking cigarettes.
Had a kid like it was 50 you know,
I mean I just love him.
Great second bad motherfucker.
And it's also,
I liked the fact that he's a real artist,
like with food he made,
made me watching his show,
the no reservation show.
Maybe reconsider what food is not,
not,
you know,
I always appreciated food but I always said,
oh this guy,
this restaurant's great.
Like we used to go to great restaurants all the time and we'd be like,
oh I found this great Italian place.
We'd go have bottled wine.
Oh it's food's awesome.
But I didn't think about the food as art history.
Yes.
The creativity that goes into like change,
turning it on its ear like I had to,
I had a,
at this wedding I had some salmon and some steak and salmon.
Steak is pretty standard and I,
and I had,
and I've been alive a long time and I hate that salmon,
that steak with a certain sauce on it.
And I stopped,
I stopped and I went,
all right,
hold on.
Something is going on here and,
and I'm,
I'm,
I'm having a little issue cause I've never had salmon like this.
And for me to say I've never had sandwich,
he'd beaten 1 million times or I've never had steak that tastes like this.
That's a big fucking deal.
Especially cause I really pay attention.
And I ran down there and I saw this cook with a ponytail,
kind of a skinny dude.
And I was like,
yeah,
what
are you doing?
What happened?
He goes,
Oh,
do you like it?
I
said,
yeah,
I like it.
It's a little transcendent.
That's how I feel helped me.
I'll get exaggerated.
I,
and even,
and,
and I said,
and correct me if I'm wrong sir,
but you cut small pieces here and you are taking into consideration the
relationship between the meat and you're crazy delicious Yam cake.
Yeah.
And you're,
and,
and this sauce that looks like it was made in heaven,
I've never seen green that you split,
you kind of spill just so it looked like kind of like,
oh,
it looks like fucking,
it looked like a fucking green pond that I could drink from.
Meanwhile,
he goes,
he looks at me.
He goes,
yes.
He said,
relationship is very important,
as is proportion.
Most people think they need to be quite a big piece,
but the minute you see it,
I go,
I finished the sentence.
I want more.
He goes,
exactly.
Here's why he's wrong,
because he's never had barbecue in Texas.
If he did,
he would want to eat until his fucking body wanted to explode.
I had a bunch of fixins.
I went to this place called blacks.
It was outside of a Austin.
It is the oldest barbecue place in Texas.
I put a picture of it up on my Instagram of the food,
me and Aubrey and my buddy Ben O'brien.
We had the most insane beef ribs I've ever eaten in my life.
Beef ribs are generally kind of chewing,
not these fucking things.
They cooked them for years.
They said they shot that cal in the 80s and they've been cooking up ever since.
Aubrey brought some into the office.
I think it was from blocks is the,
and he brought it from Frederick's,
which is another insane place in,
but that's in Austin.
See that on the left,
that piece of meat that was so fucking insanely tender and delicious,
that place it's a,
it's uh,
apparently it's a real landmark in Texas.
Blacks,
like everything else was really good.
Like the spare ribs were good,
the brisket was really good,
but God damn,
if you go there,
you got to fuck with those beef ribs.
They're insane.
Like we were all just blown away.
Like the three of us were like,
what the fuck on?
And we ain't until we almost exploded and it looks ridiculous.
Yeah.
I that that go go eat at blocks and then go to the honors academy and go have
John Wolfe take you through one workout.
He's great dude.
He's great.
I was like,
Hey John,
what do you like?
First of all,
he's couldn't be thicker.
I was like,
what are you,
what's your national very flexible.
He's ridiculously flexible with long arms.
He's like,
yeah,
I'm Japanese,
Mexican and English.
Interesting.
Very war.
Like combination of people's very warlike,
sweetest guy ever law.
He's the last guy would ever called warlike know Swedish shit.
And I can put you in a world of pain with no weights just using bodyweight.
Oh yeah.
He has a crazy hip complex series that he does,
which we did.
Yeah.
Oh,
it's amazing.
Right?
It's so weird.
Like you kept weird pain afterwards.
You're like,
oh,
why does it inside of my Dick Hurting?
So true to do all this,
we're just going to take his,
just a mobility.
I was like,
all right,
well Aubrey and I were there,
um,
for my show.
I did a show at the Moody Theater.
She's insane.
Probably one of the best shows of my life.
It was amazing.
It's crazy.
God Damn.
I Love Austin,
Texas.
Fuck.
I love that place.
But,
uh,
we did this place,
this a moody theater,
and before the theater we worked out at the Ana gym and then went to,
uh,
the zero gravity float spa or they have their perfect day.
But when we were there,
John was doing his,
uh,
certification seminars.
He does these,
uh,
honored certification seminars.
It shows these potential trainers,
people that want a career in the fitness industry shows him all sorts of
different ways to work out differently.
He's a scientist.
Oh yeah.
I was telling you about,
um,
the sky workout with Lou [inaudible],
who is a old school bodybuilder.
Strong man.
He's 68,
almost 59.
How's he look?
He looks fantastic.
He's,
he's,
uh,
originally from north Italy,
so he's got that Austrian,
like he's just got huge hands and a big kind of strong,
solid,
crazy.
Yeah,
he's,
but,
but when you say crazy,
like he's the guy,
I'll take you for 20 minutes and work you out and target your muscles in a
certain way and you're like,
this isn't doing,
I just feel like I could do more.
And then the next day you're sore shit.
Like he just,
he's a scientist.
He knows he's got 160 clients and it's because he just knows what the hell he's
doing.
And you're in and out in 20,
25 minutes.
Well,
if you could still look good in your sixties.
Oh,
he looks fantastic.
Ripped.
What's his Dick Taste like?
A,
I'm glad you asked.
We don't.
I don't do that and child I am.
I couldn't.
I was like,
I should ask that.
I always do.
That's all.
That's all I do.
That's all I do is such an idiot.
So what does he look like?
Like in his sixties pull a picture of this gentleman [inaudible] p p fit gym on
a Lincoln.
If you guys want to go.
I'm always impressed with two tour in their sixties a little crazy.
He's 59 like a Steve Maxwell deep in his sixties.
[inaudible] 65 dude's a stud.
It's an animal.
He all he does.
It goes all over the world and trains people.
Just,
just little seminars.
What his philosophy.
He's a fascinating guy.
He has a lot of philosophies.
He's a very intelligent kind.
He's very well read when it comes to uh,
ancient methods of fitness and there is that kind of 60 years old.
He looks great.
I know he does though.
Parents amazing too.
It's better than Red van did.
I can't believe he was on that.
Yeah,
he looks amazing,
Dude.
Yes.
Skin looks great.
Yup.
He's,
he's,
he eats a lot of fruits and vegetables,
some meat.
He's working on that posture.
Then what's up with that neck?
Fourth thing it's got going on there,
straighten up fellow.
He's been working out in his whole life.
Worry about shit.
He can,
he can,
he can do shit to you and by the way,
that's exactly what he looks like right now and he can do shit to you that just,
he just targets those muscles.
So this is just,
he's given people a stair workout.
All he's doing here is warming you up.
You run,
you run maybe 10 stairs,
just a warm up,
you're not going to stretch before.
Warms the muscles up and then you just start slowly lifting and then by the time
20 minutes is over,
you're begging for money.
Yeah.
They say not to stretch now before lifting weights.
Stretching actually can take away some of your performance.
Yeah.
The problem with that is I wonder if that's the case with martial arts because
I,
I mean I think there's a reason why people in ballet and dance and gymnastics
stretch.
I don't know how to gymnastics,
I might've made that up,
but certainly dance,
they stretch before they work out.
They stretch before they practice.
Cause I think martial arts,
there's certain amount of flexibility that's necessary to achieve like that
fluid motion.
Like if you're bound up and tense and tight,
you're not going to have the same sort of dexterity.
You're not going to have the same ability to place your foot wherever you want
it to.
You're going to be,
there's going to be some resistance,
but that resistance might actually be okay if you're doing something like
squatting or jumping.
Right.
You know what I mean?
Like I think there's a different need that the body has when it comes to like,
I've always been like real skeptical people telling you not to stretch.
It was a way to scratch I think.
And I do agree.
I think it depends on the kind of movement you're doing and stuff,
but they say that the first thing you want to do is warm the muscle up.
But also overstretching.
Luckily a lot of yoga people develop arthritic conditions because the,
the tendons are genetically,
you know,
you either have longer tendons are shorter tenants.
So,
and I was like a hinge of a door.
Some people can only open their door this much.
Other people went to open the door all the way.
Like you have very flexible,
you're really flexible.
And so when people overstretched those tenants,
what happens is if the tenant is shorter and you're trying to make it longer,
what will happen is the joint will start to compromise and you'll pull more of
the joint apart.
Therefore you get water or,
or,
or air into that joint,
which apparently is what creates an arthritic condition.
So when you're constantly expanding and not doing some contractual work,
that's where you're at.
So it's like yoga people,
they're not lifting weights as well.
Is that what it is after stretching too much?
And it does.
It doesn't,
it does weaken the muscle when you're stretching.
Um,
you know,
cold when you're cold and you're stretching and then you go and play soccer.
A lot of girls especially were tearing their ACL and then when they had them
start changing the way they trained,
uh,
more weightlifting,
more,
um,
more warming than muscle up beforehand.
That's how they were avoiding more of those ACL tears.
That's fascinating.
Yeah,
it's,
it's interesting how they learn.
You do thank you.
Keep going.
It's interesting how they learn too.
It's like they almost have to like watch people fuck up and go,
Whoa,
what's he doing wrong?
Like why is he getting injured?
You know,
one of the things Maxwell I feel about everything in life.
Sure.
Like the next time we go into a war,
like I was talking about,
I hope that we learn and we go,
what's the history of the region?
I mean we may,
you learn by mistakes you learned the hard way.
Well you should listen to Dan Carlin's series on world war one.
Have you heard of?
I have.
And I remember when he was talking about the difference between the World War
One and the previous wars and that like they had,
they had all these ideas about war chivalry honor standing up and shit went
away.
I had no right,
well give cause cause with a machine gun you,
you all die.
Yeah.
Well not only that,
they started introducing things like bomb gas.
Yeah.
Fritz harbor while Fritz Haber was a fascinating character because you know that
most fascinating.
Yeah.
Because he learned how he figured out a way to take nitrogen out of the air,
create ammonia.
This is from radio lab and uh,
that ammonia is what they think that half the population of the world today has
Fritz harbor nitrogen in their bloodstream.
The reason we can feed 7 billion people in soon 10 billion is primarily because
of the process for its hopper invented,
which is getting nitrogen out of the air and into the soil,
which is how you create fertilizer.
Problem is it's also how you create explosives and poison gas,
if you will.
He was the first one to figure that out.
How to use poison gas on troops,
chlorine gas.
So while he was being awarded Nobel Prize of Science for creating the hopper
method,
he was also being wanted for war crimes by the United States.
Like gassing people.
Yes.
And the way they died,
apparently if you listen to the radio lab podcasts,
they drown in their own phlegm.
Well,
how about what they,
what they do,
how they end it,
which is he created an insecticide called [inaudible] a,
which is an insecticide.
And the reason it has is that client A's,
because it has a certain smell to it,
you put an,
you put a scent in it,
so you know when it's in the air to avoid that area,
uh,
the way they do with gasoline,
gasoline doesn't have that scent.
They put that scent in there.
Um,
that's an artificial sense.
So you know,
if there's a gas leak and the same as icon a,
when the Nazis were figuring out what to do with their quote unquote Jewish
problem,
and they talked about the final solution,
they said,
let's,
let's use this xy clon a and take the scent out.
It'll be xy.
Clon B and the irony is for its harbor,
who was the secular Jew who,
who was a patriot,
a German patriot,
have figured out a way to have feed half the world.
His tos technology ended up killing his extended family and his friends.
It's Kinda crazy man.
He actually wound up leaving Germany and he was ostracized by the rest of the
world.
It's a fascinating at hot dust.
It's called the bad podcast.
It's one of the radio lab ones.
It was amazing.
It was a great one that got out now about elements about this woman who was
going crazy and a lithium was the only thing that uh,
she's bipolar.
Lithium brings her way back tomorrow and we'll,
lithium is just an element.
It's assault.
Apparently.
I didn't know that he was upset,
some sort of of that you need to listen.
Does he listen to crisper?
But this,
this lithium thing that uh,
she's taking is killing her.
It's killing her.
It's causing your kidneys to fail.
So she has to get off the lithium.
And so they're talking to her while this was going on in the podcast.
He's saying like this is so complicated from,
because this is one thing that's killing me,
but it's also allowing me to be me.
Really,
really fascinating.
Yeah.
The crisper,
we've talked about it a few times on this podcast.
The ability to manipulate genes and this is the beginning Crispr,
if you've never heard that one,
that's another great one.
Radio lab is the Shit fucking amazing podcasts.
So interesting.
You know,
so many fascinating,
fascinating subjects that cover what would you do if they committed,
manipulate your genes,
what do you want different?
It's gotta be a real problem when people do do it because there's going to be,
there's going to be no regular people left.
I think we're looking at life now as if you go back to the early forms of life
that we're on this planet,
just single celled organisms turned into multi-celled organisms.
They evolve from random mutations and you know,
natural selection,
all the different various factors that cause a person to come out of the
primordial slime that we originated from.
If you look at what we are now,
we look at all that is like this.
This is like how it progresses.
You know,
this is how a dinosaur it turns into a bird and this is all we can see.
These are the really pry evolution.
And you know,
most of the Republican candidates don't want to talk about that.
This is crazy.
If you look at all that stuff,
we look at this timeline,
it's this long,
slow,
crazy timeline.
It's,
it's really difficult to trace for the average human mind.
You know,
you look it up a primate and you look at a human,
you go,
well,
human used to be something like that a long time ago.
What?
Fuck.
And you know,
and he would see pictures of cave people kind of get it.
But that's 60,000 years ago.
We said,
well now a hundred thousand years ago,
million years ago,
whatever the fuck it was,
it seemed so long.
It's hard.
It doesn't really register.
It's like when someone says $1 trillion,
so like,
um,
okay,
a trillion years,
I don't get it.
Right.
You know that it's going to happen like that.
There's going to come on roll our own evolution on g.
Yes.
And I think it's only one part of the bigger problem.
I think our ability to control our own bodies is just a part of the evolution of
technology and the evolution of technology that allows us to do that is also
going to create artificial life,
which is many,
many more times complicated.
Well it takes the element of chance out of the entire equation.
So when we're able to control exactly how we look and what we develop into and
what we are resistant to,
it's kind like what we're doing with crops.
And I think I also,
I feel like we are us,
we are going to be able to take this machine,
which is what we are,
which is kind of a fascinating and incredibly complex machine,
but technology is going to render this machine kind of obsolete.
I feel like,
I feel like ultimately we're going to trade in this machine for uh,
something that works a lot more efficiently and it's more and lives longer and
all that stuff.
If you could do it,
why not?
Yeah,
but that's even assuming that what we are is going to maintain.
I don't think.
I think we are technological
caterpillar.
That's what I think.
I think we're a caterpillar that becomes a butterfly and right now we're in the
middle of making of cocoon.
That's really interesting.
I just don't say [inaudible] you mean mentally?
I think life.
I think if we create artificial life we create some sort of an artificial thing
that somehow or another profits on it staying alive.
Like there's a reason why we want to stay alive.
We want to procreate,
we're going to keep the human race alive and we want to react to all of our
instincts,
all of our natural instincts and the natural reward systems that have been put
in place over the eons to make sure that we keep breathing and keep staying
alive.
That's where your ego comes from.
That's where lust comes from and greed and jealousy.
All these things are like they're motivating factors for you to improve on your,
your condition and and and keep fucking and keep making more babies.
Why are they covering thy neighbor's wife?
Why?
Cause he want to fuck that bitch and shoot some loads into her and make a baby
with her.
I've got to make babies.
You got to keep going.
I think that's a really shitty design and I think it ultimately,
it's main goal is to for it for the biological entity to create a more
sophisticated and much more efficient entity.
And that's what it's going to do.
There's a,
this is the caterpillar and this caterpillar is going to become some
indescribable butterfly,
some butterfly that can manipulate its environment like never before.
Some butterfly that literally creates worlds.
If you,
well,
if you,
if you extrapolate that and if you then say,
look,
I have,
um,
all my biological needs are taken care of so I don't have to worry about
disease.
I don't have to worry about food.
Um,
and I'm optimal.
I'm,
I'm at my optimal,
my machine can,
can adapt and it probably won't die.
You're still left with something that's very interesting to me,
which is now.
Now,
if you've taken out the equation that sort of rudimentary need to procreate,
that rudimentary needs to replicate yourself,
that rudimentary need to sort of,
or rudimentary,
it might be the wrong word,
but,
but the need to,
to be immortal,
to keep your genes through whatever it is going.
Then you're kind of left with why yourself and why.
You know like what am I doing pleasure,
but what is all know pleasure is different.
I think what you're getting,
but what?
Positive experiences,
right?
Fun,
excitement,
pleasure.
What end positive to know yourself better.
What are those things?
The question is what are those things?
What is positive?
What is,
what is love?
What is happiness?
What is friendship?
What does achievement?
All those things are the rewards.
All those things are rewards for behavior.
That's ultimately going to lead to procreation.
Bonding leads to community.
Community leads to safety,
safety leads to your children's surviving.
All those things are connected.
Yes.
Procreation,
acquiring of things becoming more more valuable as a a member of your community
and more desirable as a possible breeding candidate.
All those things,
they're,
they're all,
they all contribute to ultimately to procreation.
That's like a
big part of what everything that we do is,
but then there's another side which is play.
You could define as that what you do for the sake of doing.
Right,
right.
And that's probably when you're most yourself.
So if,
if play is the case,
then it seems like we were just talking about this.
Like people say,
I don't know what to do with my life.
And I always say the younger people,
I'm like,
look man,
I don't know what to do with your life either.
But I do know that it's really fun to get good at a language like watching you
play pool.
That's a language that something you've closed,
you,
you've,
you've come very close to being as really,
really good at and you have a deep understanding of it.
There's a d you gain a deep understanding this great pleasure in being fluent in
a language like say pool or Jujitsu or boxing or even another language or,
or in an instrument like guitar.
I think you develop an understanding and sometimes that's that you can't
necessarily put into words.
It's something you have to experience.
But God damn it is,
it's satisfying.
It's satisfying in of itself.
But why?
Well,
well,
okay,
so here's my answer.
I think,
well,
I don't have the answer,
but I think it may lie in the area of understanding and coming closer to
something maybe people call consciousness,
uh,
coming closer to something that's bigger than yourself,
communion with,
uh,
something that is,
without measure,
but that,
you know,
is there,
don't you think though also that if you don't look at it like in some sort of
spiritual way,
but look at in terms of just biology and natural reward systems that are put
into place by success,
success leading to procreation,
people that are really good at things,
you'd get good at,
things that are difficult to solve.
Like solving puzzles is integral to survival.
That's integral to innovation leads to more efficiency,
more efficiency leads to more food,
more food leads to people staying alive.
The better you get at something,
the more you're rewarded with the,
the those positive feelings,
those natural ward systems that are put in place to make sure that people figure
out their fucking part on this world.
Figure out their way through this life until they can invent artificial life,
get them hooked on material possessions,
get them hooked on this idea of getting the newest,
greatest,
latest shit.
Get them hooked on technology.
You need a watch that you can swipe and you need all these different new crazy
ants.
And the more these things get fueled,
the more,
the more the technology grows,
the more the inevitability of an artificial life form exists.
Okay?
But,
but here's,
here's why.
Here's what I'm so blown away right now.
Meet you man.
But here,
take your pants off for a second.
Here's a camera,
right?
Oh boy.
Shit.
Here's where I trip trip.
Sorry,
I'm 48 trip.
You know,
shots.
Um,
here's,
here's what,
uh,
what I,
I think though,
so when you talk about technology,
most of us are talking about a tool you can use for the here and now.
Um,
and,
and that technology allows you to speak to people more clearly in faster and get
places faster and all that stuff.
They're all tools,
but then there's another side to fucking reality that I'm fascinated with and,
and I don't know why it's there,
but there's something that goes beyond experience.
Uh,
there's a reality that is beyond experience.
And you know what I mean by that?
I'll tell you the number.
Infinity is not something we'll ever see,
but it's something we imagine and something we use in mathematics.
Um,
negative numbers,
negative integers and things are mathematical constructs that you can't actually
see and don't have material measurement necessarily,
but they are theoretical and we use them and benefit from it.
Here's another great example.
The mathematician in 1860,
who spends his whole life thinking of some weird mathematical equation.
It's got no bearing on a material world whatsoever until 150 years later.
And now we're using it to measure the difference between fucking,
you know,
the crater on Mars and how it relates to things like that.
And I just think that sometimes whatever human beings have an imagination,
it's put there,
the imagination has put there somewhere.
And I'm not getting into this mystical stuff.
I'm just saying,
I am curious to know why,
why we have,
what separates us from animals is potential is,
is anything we can imagine seems to be within our reach in terms of reality.
And I eventually,
yes and I think,
I think that nostalgia that need to go physically further than we've ever gone
before and and mentally for them,
we've ever gone before.
W there is no limit to human potential there.
It seems to be zero limit to him and potential to the point where we will render
ourselves out.
We're very biology and even our mental paradigms obsolete where we will achieve
in.
But wait a minute,
will we be Wieden?
Exactly.
Won't will be something better.
That's what I mean.
What we'll do,
we evolve.
So you're essentially agreeing with me.
We're going to create them.
How we going to create an artificial life form?
Well,
that artist's life form might be the butterfly,
right?
Yes.
If we,
if we need absolutely to constantly innovate and we do,
no one is ever going to look at a computer and say,
we're done.
No one's going to look at an iPhone se there's no need for the six s the six is
perfect.
Let's stop there.
Who Needs 12 megapixels?
I got eight.
I'm happy as fuck.
I take great Instagram pictures.
No,
no one's going to be happy.
We're going to get bored.
And it's a part,
it's,
it's an inexorable part of being a human.
There's this weird thing you can't take out of us.
Where we look with,
with all as the guy who decides to live in a log house and go fishing every day
is the guy lives off the land.
What?
Like there's so freaky that we have TV shows dedicated to them.
Yes.
Like let's watch these people
in Alaska walking anachronisms those are,
those are like throwbacks,
right?
I mean,
that's what's interesting is that there they're bucking the grid and saying,
I can still do it the way we did 150 years.
There's that and there's also the fact that they're out there braving the wild,
they're braving the atmosphere there,
braving the harsh parts of the world that we don't want to visit like too,
like that's all the thing about life below zero that show that I love.
Yeah,
it's 200 fucking miles above the arctic circle is where these people live.
Some of them,
you know what I mean?
Just fuck man.
Sue Akins,
a chick that I had on the show,
she's amazing.
If you've never listened to that podcast,
it's one of the best ones I ever did.
Bailey.
Oh my God.
It's a fascinating woman,
man.
She's in her fifties,
lives up in Alaska by herself in this fucking,
you can't even have buildings up there because it's,
it's,
it's on this land that has to have temporary structures because of whatever
goofy fucking law there's in place.
So she has tents.
They're these giant tents.
We'd like w wires and you know,
very thick canvas.
But they're fucking tense man.
And she's out there with grizzly bears and wolves and she,
everywhere she goes,
she's strapped.
She got attacked by a bear.
Fucking bitter head broke her hip,
fucked her up.
She went to the hospital.
I mean,
she was a fucking,
uh,
honor back for like seven days before they found her.
She went to the hospital,
got fixed up,
went back,
shot the fucking bear and ate it.
She's the most gangster bitch on the planet.
It does.
She's like right up there with Ronda Rousey.
She's so gangs.
Just Rhonda.
If she's 50.
Hey,
this chick chick is hard fucking Corp.
Fascinating though.
Like that this woman chooses to,
that's where she's getting her jollies.
There's her,
that's how I love that lady.
That's she's her house,
man.
That's her fucking house.
That's where she lives.
He's got like a wooden side.
The top of that is all cloth.
It's a tent.
He lives up there alone.
Yes,
and she got up.
She occasionally has visitors and now she travels.
She has children and grandchildren.
She does whatever the fuck she wants.
But that's what those things look like.
They're,
they're,
they're temporary structures.
She gets her gas flowing in and these gigantic planes and she fills a planes up.
She's like a waypoint.
She owns like a filling station up there and that's how she makes her living.
And she also,
um,
people can come stay in like she has structures up there.
They can come stay in Caribou Hunt and do a bunch of different things and she'll
take people on like guided tours of the area.
Now it's especially look at that.
There's the,
uh,
the place where she lives.
What's that?
That's amazing.
Oh,
it's so amazing.
She's,
she's incredible.
But it's,
she's not just dealing with the,
the environment.
She's dealing with the animals.
She's dealing with mortality and you know,
she's Liz's subsistence lifestyle up there.
Most of what she gets,
either she gets flown in or she shoots it and eats it.
Go Scroll back up to the top.
There was those,
who are those people that they loved it too.
Oh yeah.
Cc she provides like this,
it says hunting and fishing.
No,
those are Caribou.
Those are Caribou antlers.
They have these crazy antlers.
So those are actually reindeer.
I mean that's what a rain here is.
So the relative of the reindeer,
like pretty similar.
So kabak where she's at,
she has these,
a hunting camps to come up there because these people see you have to,
you have self guided camps.
She just,
the Caribou are up there and they go by every year.
There's like a time when they go up there,
it was like August or some shit.
And during that time that's when they fly people up there and they go caribou
hunting.
But they'll,
they'll walk by and these massive herds,
hundreds and hundreds of Caribou sometimes and he'd just lay down,
you pick one and you shoot it and you eat it and you get hundreds of pounds of
the most delicious meat you'll every in your life.
That's,
that's a moose actually.
Yeah,
that's a,
that's a different animal.
But that's a,
that's the most too.
But the other one,
we're a Caribou and they're,
they're unbelievably delicious too.
So our Moose man,
I had some Moose Sirloin.
Neither did I cooked from last year when I shot that Moose last year,
I cooked it the other day.
The vegan?
No,
the food is that meat is so good like you,
if you ate it at a restaurant,
it'd be like your favorite meat ever,
but they can't.
You don't sell Moose commercial and still haven't gotten any from me.
Dude.
Come over man.
When he come over,
come over.
It's quick.
Maybe I'll do it today.
Come on we cryo.
Let's do it.
Come on over.
I'll class Tim Kennedy.
I was watching talking to mass.
He was cryotherapy.
I said,
do you shiver?
And he said,
I do.
Well with the cold
fucking stud.
You get very excited about him.
Yes.
He's my boyfriend,
Anthony Bordain jurists and Tim Kennedy's mind.
I fantasize about just being buddies.
What would you guys do together?
Hunt wild boar on horseback with spears.
Duh.
It sounds like an effective way to shoot guns and then could you have guns and
watch action films?
Why don't you just shoot the boar with guns if you have guns?
Because spears are more macho and got to,
you got to have good throwing motion.
Yeah.
I've thought that about bow hunting.
Why?
Why bow hunt?
Why do you have to bow hunt?
Because it's more of a challenge I guess,
but the idea of challenges to kind of dangerous or you're hunting I guess,
and also for the animal.
A lot of wounded.
I've been watching a lot of hunting shows where they show wounded animals with
tired of,
do you think like once the mystery of something goes away,
you you want to move on?
I'm like,
what is it about archery?
Oh,
archery is a great discipline.
I love archery as a discipline.
Yeah.
It's a fun thing to do.
Like just shooting targets come over the house and I will fucking shoot some
targets today.
I'll have to get one of my little girl bows out for you to use,
but I need a 60 pound the nineties too hard for me.
I don't use the 90 anymore.
I use a 70 I think I can pull back a 70 could ne you might struggle.
You had a hard time with the 80 last time.
Yeah.
Um,
but um,
it's hard man.
It's,
it's also something you shouldn't,
shouldn't start out with.
Just start out with like a 40 to 50.
Yeah.
Just get used to the motion and also get used to the fundamentals of archery.
You don't want to be struggling with the bow while you are learning how to do
it.
I take creatine now.
Do I do make
you bigger?
It makes your face fat.
I'm a thinker.
I'm carrying water weight.
You guys make sure Facebook like I'm on my period.
Um,
but it's,
it's just a fun thing to do.
Like a luck lining up to target,
keeping everything straight straight.
And there's something that when you're doing something that's really difficult,
like it's hard to get the Arrow to go where you want it to go.
It takes a lot of practice.
I shoot about a hundred hours a day every day.
I have archery targets all over my yard.
I have like five of them,
six of them in one side.
I just ordered a giant elk.
It hasn't gotten here yet,
but it's fucking huge.
Rubber elk sounds like set up somewhere they should be for me.
There are shy and don't want to do,
what do I do?
A giant who's this giant rubber elk for?
It's Joe Rogan.
Ah,
yeah,
he's got a rubber pig as well.
A very popular,
a lot of people have them,
the giant rubber elk that hunt with bow hunting with El cause you want to make
sure that you're going to hit that spot.
You want to,
and that's looking at an animal is different than looking at a target,
you know,
and some like a lot of what archery is is repetition,
repetition and muscle memory.
And it's got to like be ingrained in your mind how you line a shot up and what,
what,
what are the movements when you release that Arrow.
See I love all that stuff.
Yeah,
that's great.
I just like,
that's why like,
you know,
boxing,
I like working out with somebody like at box and burn this Guy Chris Man Aaron
and his fight and for the IB,
uh Oh,
or Ibo title,
he's defending his international title on Spike TV.
What is it?
Uh,
anyway.
Um,
and he like just learning how like,
just like the intricacies of boxing.
I know I'm never going to master it or get really good at it,
but I just like reaching,
I like just reaching its,
if you think about it,
48 years old,
it's silver.
Well what's going to happen?
I'm going to be thrown into it when the Mongols come,
they're going to throw me into a pit.
I,
you'd have to bucks that guy.
Let's bet on him and all of a sudden going to surprise everybody with my fucking
by Jab,
pop,
and then it'd be like Brad Pitt and that movie snack.
That's all I want to be.
I just want to be a gypsy fighter with that body.
You want to talk like that to you guys?
I know.
Uh,
yeah man.
Getting good at things is fun.
I mean,
but you know,
the ultimate question like we were talking about before,
it's like,
why is it fun?
Like what is it about it?
I don't know,
but I just know that for me to stay happy and this is my own craziness,
I need to constantly be engaged in things that challenged me.
That's it.
I've tried a bunch of other ways to be happy.
I can't just chill out and relax all the time.
It's just not in me.
Me Neither.
I'm that.
I like to relax.
Like I do love relaxation,
but I have to feel like I've earned it.
I don't like relax like regular laziness,
like waking and baking and getting up.
That leaves me with this hollow anxiety,
like I can't do that.
I've tried it.
I've tried to just be lazy.
It fucks with my head too much gray.
I can only appreciate watching television or going to the movies if I've done my
work,
if I haven't done my work,
I don't,
you know,
and there's in achievement too,
there's happiness and getting shit done.
Yeah,
but that's also the house.
It goes back to what we were talking about where like I'm trying to work on this
new hour now.
Now I shot my one hour editing it and I'm throwing all that away.
And you've got to start with new stuff.
What drives me,
actually I swear to God is not laughs I've had enough.
You know,
you can get inoculated to that.
It's a beautiful thing to get a lot of laughs.
But what was more important is I want to see what else I can come home with.
I want to see if I can tap into my real potential and come up with something
even better.
That challenge is again going,
what is my potential?
Like what,
what am I really having me and how much time if I spend like eight hours a day
thinking about as opposed to two hours a day.
Well that's,
that's what nags at me.
It's also you realize as you know an artist,
men as an artist,
you're constantly growing and you're constantly getting nuts.
One of the number one problems with older comedians that have the act from 20
years ago,
we've seen those guys before.
Time passes you by comedy is like a sand castle.
You build it.
I mean people can look at the photos of it from the,
from the past,
but this shit's gone.
It's gone.
And once it's gone,
it's gone.
Like if Lenny Bruce came back from the dead today and went up Saturday night at
the comedy store,
he,
you know,
plate of Dick's,
he die.
He would cause the co the culture has changed if you go and listen to his,
and I'm not a hater at all.
I mean,
I think Lenny Bruce is the most important figure in all of standup.
He's the original.
He's the Godfather.
You over my house.
I've Lenny Bruce posters.
I have a concert poster from the Fillmore.
I have,
uh,
one of his concert movies that's framed in a poster to me.
He's like,
that was the original.
He fucking took a lot of crazy chances and got arrested for it and really
ultimately went crazy the last parts of his life where him going to court doing
heroin died on his fucking bathroom floor doing heroin.
Just he was going to court all the time and he would do shows where he was just
completely gone.
He would just read legal transcripts to the audience.
There's,
there's,
there's video of it.
Yeah,
you can watch it.
I bought a bunch of these videos and watch them with VHS was like,
wow,
this guy just went crazy.
But at the end he was just going through so dig,
the judge says,
and he's like,
like reading these transcripts with no comedy.
There was nothing funny about it.
He just lost all of his point and was obsessed with this.
So he laid the foundation.
He laid the groundwork that for guys like you and me and everybody else,
everybody else that does stand out,
but one work today,
if you're the same act,
if he was alive today,
he'd figure it out.
He'd figured out,
you know,
he's a comic.
He'd figure it out,
but he'd have to grow.
Like everyone has to grow your,
your,
your comedy grows and it changes as the culture changes.
There's,
if you go back to like Eddie Murphy Raw,
there's some fucking terrible homophobic shit.
Eddie Murphy Raw.
I was there.
I went to his car.
I went to the actual concert.
But did you think it was terrible and homophobic at that time?
Not that,
no.
It was okay.
It was acceptable.
And that was when I wasn't,
I've never been a,
you know,
I've always been sensitive to people's feelings.
I was never wanting to gang up on something.
He was gay,
but I just didn't think of it as something that was bad.
Oh,
speaking of which,
I forgot to bring this up.
I wanted to,
um,
uh,
Jamie go to my Twitter page and there's a tweet that I posted today about this
woman from Kentucky that is the Kentucky clerk.
Denies Marriage license under God's authority.
There's a video of these guys.
Did you see the video?
These guys,
this is a new one.
This is from today.
This is a new person.
Like there was the other person.
This woman is talking to these gay guys that want to get married and she won't
let them and they're saying under whose authority?
Like why,
what the video would drive you crazy.
Why does it matter of faith to put those on,
put those on,
check this out.
Go full screen.
Cause this is awesome.
Let's to issue marathons
the nines or stay based on what I would ask you,
why are you not going shitty marriage licenses today?
Because underwriting authority.
Are you nodding
to do this?
They got to know you didn't treat us.
I don't like to out till you are interrupting.
You can,
you can call the police.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
This is a change which makes our country modern.
This is a shift in culture.
I mean this is what this is like.
That woman that's saying that is crazy.
She's just,
she's locked in an ideology and she's like,
her very job relies on the government.
I mean that's what the government is telling her.
I mean,
she's a government employee.
The government is telling her that you ha,
I mean the supreme court has made a decision.
You have to allow these people to get married and she's like,
nope,
I believe in God.
Well first I think though that the,
we also have to recognize it.
I don't agree with her because I'm not a religious guy,
but she is a new agreement is that it is a matter of faith for her and if she's
going to be a government employee though,
she's got to uphold the law of the land and we live in a secular society,
which is a separation of church and state.
Do we really?
What about one nation under God?
That's the same stain that one of people,
it's the same state that wanted to teach.
The school board wanted to teach creative design instead of evolution.
Isn't it the same state where they get the devil statute?
Now they have to have a devil statue,
which,
which the state has to have a devil statute as a satanist one.
The religious right to put a devil statue or the Jesus statutes,
they have equal representation.
Do you mean no,
no,
no.
Satanist.
Same.
Yeah.
No sadness.
Sadness,
statue.
Find out.
It's crazy though,
right?
This is really where it gets Detroit.
No,
I think,
I don't think that's it.
Um,
there's one,
there's one in the south,
I'm pretty sure.
Yeah.
Is that,
what's that one?
A July 6th right there above Fox News.
That's probably the most,
whenever he,
whenever in doubt and you look over something ridiculous.
Fox News,
I mean it's a difficult thing
though because somebody has a strong religious conviction.
For example,
they're pro choice because it shows that,
I mean a pro life because they think that abortion is murder.
Go back to that so we could see that.
That was awesome.
Look at this statue.
It's a pretty cool statute by the way.
Look at it.
It's amazing.
It's pretty dope.
So I guess it is Detroit.
I felt like it was happening somewhere in that,
look at that.
That's the Angel Lucifer,
right?
Look at I go ahead.
Well,
it's a say tannic statute that I believe they're putting up as a goof to say
tannic temple file file file photo provided by the satanic 10 by the way,
I've been accused of being a satanist house.
I went to a Duncan Trussell performed at one of the little love [inaudible].
What's his name?
Something.
The son or the grandson or something like that was getting married.
Duncan Trussell performed is satanic puppet show at this guy.
And I went there and I wore the guys tee shirt and now there's like videos
accusing me of being a satanist.
I just like to clear the air.
I am neither a a religious person nor am I an anti religious person.
Um,
I am not a satanist but I have done mushrooms and I've done some pretty powerful
psychedelic drugs.
So the um,
possibility of there being another much more powerful and wise force out there,
it does not escape me.
I think it is absolutely possible that there's something way more wise than us
that we're not totally in touch with.
But I also don't think it has a dick.
So I don't think it's a,
he,
I don't think it's a his,
you know,
Christians either do Muslims,
either the tutors,
but why did they say in his presence?
Because his word,
if you were to,
for example,
give a name to y'all,
we can say I law and Yahweh,
but Yahweh among the orthodox is to trample on their sensibilities because when
you give a name to God,
okay,
when you give a name,
when you say God is,
this is,
this is what's heretical about the idea of Jesus Christ to Jews and to Muslims.
Because if you create parameters around God,
if you suggest God as a man or a woman,
if you suggest God has a name,
uh,
then you are assuming to understand his greatness and his infinity hypnotize me
while you're rubbing your forums there is saying this the same time I feel like
locked into your gaze.
That's what happens when you get,
when I start talking about religion,
God,
his Dick.
But here's my question.
When his name,
see I think some religion I didn't.
Christianity is a powerful religion when used the right fit.
So a lot of questions just preach love and doing unto others as you'd have them
do unto others.
It's got powerful conversion ability of some people who saw nothing and find
inspiration and love through God.
Listen,
I,
I'm not a religious guy,
but I respect whatever that conversion can be cause a lot of good things are
done in the name of Jesus Christ.
Justice alive,
the suppressive things can be done in the name of your God.
So I'm not so ready to condemn all good things.
Good things can be done.
Why are they done in the name of something that's not real and why does that
make that something not real?
More valuable,
but that may be done is what's good,
but,
but now hold on because when you say it's not real,
people have inspiration and deep feeling not real.
From there it's real and from their religion holes,
hammering nails,
building buildings.
I'm going to have to ask what is Donald Trump does?
That's the real,
yes,
son of a bitch.
He's a builder.
I think it,
I think religious communion,
prayer,
meditation and things is good for making you,
it does make sure we're humble.
Any sort of inspiration is good.
Anything that motivates you is good,
especially if it motivates you in a positive way.
It's good,
but the real problem becomes when someone like this lady decides that those two
guys can't get married because her God prevents it,
but the founding fathers had an answer to that,
which was to separate church and state.
Tommy's came along and then we had to jump back in the religious game and then
Ronald Reagan came along.
We jumped into the religious game with politics.
Now you need to get to get elected.
You,
Jesus Christ,
a Christian nation,
you have to,
you literally do.
You have to be a Christian.
You know this is a Christian nation,
Christian question.
Well,
it's not supposed to be.
It's supposed to be a nation.
One Nation under God was only created back when the McCarthy era was going on.
There are parts of this country where you for when you perform and you,
you say the word Jesus,
the room gets very quiet.
You get the wrong places,
you're going to the wrong spots.
He just didn't know where that doesn't.
They should know you by now.
You should be able to do anything you want.
Yeah,
well I do speaking and Kentucky,
there's a thing that I posted that was fucking fascinating about,
um,
the,
the dangers of mis-gendering.
Someone,
um,
that Gad Saad,
uh,
posted it and I retweeted it is adorable and it's uh,
the,
the fucking lunacy that's going on in colleges these days.
You're supposed to walk up to someone and say hi.
Nice to meet you.
What Pronoun should I use for your name?
Yes.
It's called fucking lunacy.
It's lunacy.
That's the,
that was the direction they said that you curative cause you don't want to miss
gender.
Academics have created a tyranny.
There's a tyranny to how you have to walk around and speak.
They even want to control what you say in the bedroom.
It's called tyranny in the name of equality and then the name of tolerance and
in the name of protecting the disenfranchised and the marginalized,
we have created a fucking tyranny.
I can't stand the academic world for that reason.
They drive me nuts.
They send though,
because there's so important when it comes to education happened.
Distribution of information is so important.
But socially there's this cause they were sciences.
Why?
Because there's spineless to these small majority of lunatics that make a lot of
noise.
And you know,
I'm sorry to say this and I,
I admire a great deal of professors.
I've interviewed a number of them.
They're awesome and thank God for professors and thank God for academic beds
that you know,
come up with all these ideas.
But at the same time a lot of academics are just terrified to make a stand.
They're fucking spineless cause they live in a very safe and closed environment
and they can't speak common sense a lot of times these like you people are
assholes.
It doesn't that lead to what we were talking about earlier,
we were talking about what people can tolerate.
That people are tough because of the environment that they grow up in.
And it's one of the reasons why people don't respect spoiled people.
One of the reasons why people don't respect people grow up rich.
We'll academics in a certain,
to a certain extent are spoiled in the fact that they don't have to compete in
the real world.
Of course they do is they exist in a very insulated world where they take
classes from people who have also gone through the system.
Then they become teachers.
And when they become teachers,
then they have this oppressive power over the people in their class.
And the people in their class have to listen to their ideology.
They are also living under oppressive power.
They are living under our protocol and academic protocol.
If you ever tried to get an academic to talk about anything that he's not a
hundred percent certain about,
boy are they terrified.
And the academic world is about the nastiest place,
uh,
in the,
talk about a battlefield of ideas.
When you come up with an idea that's controversial,
like,
like a Steven pinker who said that human beings are not born a blank slate or
that aggression is rewarded in indigenous cultures.
Holy Shit.
Was He lambast?
Yeah,
he got in a lot of trouble.
You didn't know.
There's a lot of science.
The chorus back set up.
Look at this.
There's office for diversity and inclusion and they get the gender binary.
He,
she,
her,
him,
hers,
his,
and then gender neutral.
They them theirs and then pronunciation as it looks.
But look at this.
Look at Z,
her and hers.
Look at that.
So here you're getting a new language.
Z here,
hears Z here hears.
These are fucking gender neutral pronouns that they've invented.
They've invented gender neutral pronouns,
pronouns.
This is insanity.
I don't see,
I don't think that kind of stuff sticks I think is just a training,
but they're trying.
This is college.
This is a university of Tennessee.
Just trying.
They're enforcing their born enforcers.
If you listen to these people there,
they are not tolerant people.
Northern Nice people.
They're not seeing.
Have you seen the woman?
Have you seen the woman,
the photo of the woman who is running this?
This is wonderful.
It's wonderful.
She's perfect.
It's in the comments of you.
If you look at the tweet that I found,
uh,
it's in my tweet,
somebody posted a photograph of this.
She perfect.
She check it just of course is.
Of course she is.
Of course she's,
she's,
no,
I don't know if she's
angry.
She doesn't have to be angry.
She's just,
well,
how about the woman who was talking about,
there was a girl in college who said that we,
she was trying to push through legislation within the college about micro
aggression and,
and we've got a monitor micro aggression.
So even your facial,
your facial,
um,
and this is Orwellian.
This is exactly what George Orwell wrote about in 1984.
Thought Crime and face crime.
It's alive and well.
Human beings love having control over other human beings.
It is.
So we all have it.
I have it.
We all have it.
If I was emperor of the world,
I know exactly what I do.
I want that power so I can do all kinds of stuff.
Because I think,
and I'm speaking to myself,
I think I'm so fair and I'm so nice that I could make everything better.
Never give anybody power.
There you go.
Oh,
there you are.
There you go.
There you are.
Oh,
look at her.
Yeah.
I grew up with this.
I went to high school with dishes up in messaging Madden.
I know all about it.
Is Madness because first of all,
I hate to say that you hate to judge someone based entirely on their parents,
but if someone's morbidly obese,
that person does not have good judgment in their own biological management.
Management of their own body has been grossly inept,
mismanaged.
That's very interesting.
It's the only way.
You also can't be too happy with herself.
This is not a poor person.
Okay.
This is,
this is a person who works in university,
came then she can't.
That's also probably not happy with herself.
Probably socially awkward,
which no one can fault anyone for those things.
The problem is when someone is in that predicament and they're choosing to
dictate the rules of engagement that other people have,
because what you're doing by creating all these gender neutral pronouns and
these new words ways you're,
you're trying to nerf the world.
That's where you're trying to do,
try to take away the awkwardness of a boy.
Looks like a girl being called a girl.
We just like,
no,
I'm a boy.
Oh,
sorry.
We'll fuck man.
You look really close to being a girl.
I'm sorry.
I'm allowed to say that.
Yeah,
but you're not okay.
Or a girl who decide she's a boy and she wants to be referred to as a boy.
She wants to be referred to as a heat.
Well,
okay,
well once you tell me that and I'm okay with it,
I don't mind.
You know,
if you say your name is Greg and your real name that you were born with was
Donna,
it doesn't bother me.
I'll call you Greg.
It doesn't bother me.
But to say that I'm the asshole because something that's completely outside the
norm is weird and sticks out.
No,
no,
no.
That's,
that's wrong.
You know,
like it's,
it's like I don't like this middle Lygo thing that I have on my hands.
It's weird,
you know?
And if I get really tan,
then it really shows up.
But I'm white so it's not that bad.
But when people would go like,
what's that on your knuckles?
I don't,
I don't like that.
I have to tell them.
But of course I go out to fit a lot.
Logo.
It's a disease.
I wish I didn't have it right,
but I do have it so I don't get upset if somebody asks me a question.
Right.
It's a normal question to ask.
My knuckles looked different than the rest of my hand.
It makes sense that they would want to know what's going on.
This isn't,
this is not like a micro aggression.
This is human curiosity.
That's something that's abnormal.
Yeah.
It's not a bad thing that it's abnormal.
It's not a bad thing.
There's a gender issue that you wish you were a woman when you were born a man
or you wish you were a man or you're born a woman.
It's not a bad thing.
It's just,
it is.
There is a difference though.
And,
and I think that we,
what we're experiencing now with the transgender movement,
and even to an extent,
the gay movement is the pendulum is swinging all the way in one direction.
And it's a,
it's a reaction to the fact that,
and this is just a fact,
when you were a man or a woman and you felt overwhelmingly like you are a
different sex and you took measures to correct your current sex or you just
dressed up in a way that made you feel more yourself.
So if you're a man and you're dressed in drag or whatever,
as a woman or for that matter,
if you were gay and you started having feelings when you include the,
the problem was that in most of our history,
you got the fucking shit kicked out of you,
killed,
tarnished your job,
but ostracized and that anger and that,
that injustice doesn't,
doesn't go away.
And so you have a lot of people that have,
are that,
that memory is very fresh.
That wound is very,
so let's have some fake pronouns.
The,
the way that,
the way the waiting she waited.
That is then,
then,
uh,
try to,
control the majority of the population behavior.
What about here?
Z H I liked that are zero.
They have those z.
It's one of them.
Yeah,
I know.
I was in,
I listened.
I went to high school in Massachusetts.
I remember when I had to,
when I had to say,
I couldn't say freshmen,
I had to say fresh person.
I dated a girl who graduated from Wellesley college with a degree in women's
studies.
Women's studies.
It's all about women.
Yeah,
I know.
It's wonderful.
I should shave her legs.
There was a white girl I suffered.
I dated a white girl.
She didn't shave her legs.
Yeah.
It's very European.
No,
it's very hippy,
bro.
That's,
it has nothing to do with European me.
That's fine.
But her,
her roommate was Greek.
I got in trouble for this,
but her feet looked like quill.
Go Bag.
And women are hot though.
Hairy feet,
bro.
Shit.
Hairy toes.
Hairy feet.
This was the girl you were with?
Nope.
The other girl.
Her,
her roommate.
When you're a younger man,
you'll fuck a bear.
It does.
I mean,
I don't know.
She was beautiful,
but she was blonde.
She's a pretty girl.
And uh,
the,
uh,
the roommate there was a girl I dated who was liberal white girl.
There was this white girl and uh,
and she majored in African studies and college.
And I went and all I did was this,
I go,
why?
Because I knew the answer was she was the liberal white girl and just wanted
other black people.
It'd be like,
you're my favorite white.
You're my favorite white and you understand us and you're down with our,
cause.
I know it wasn't because she was interested in African studies and then I said,
because I said,
why,
why?
What about why you choose to study African studies?
Not that there's anything wrong with it and not say what you come from like
European history.
Why would you care what she's telling you?
I just wanted to know the answer.
Okay.
And what was her answer?
She said her answer was,
I wish she wasn't even at a black guys.
She goes,
I find that question offensive.
And I said,
Whoa,
that's what I thought you'd say.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
But I thought you'd say why I find that question offense because I'm not
prejudice at all.
So that's a good question.
It's a good question.
If you say like,
I'm a professional poker player.
Oh,
why?
It's a fair question.
How do ma'am maybe you wouldn't say why.
Yeah,
you wouldn't say why,
but you would say we want to be a poker player.
Why?
Yeah,
that's a good question.
That's a real question.
If you said,
I want to be a professional poker player,
I would definitely say why.
People ask me what if they want,
they want to be actors and I asked him why all the time.
Why?
What is it about acting that will you want pay attention to that now?
Hold on.
Do you want what you see at the awards are going to be to come here?
Yeah.
He's not even an actor.
Kanye West and Donald Trump,
in my opinion,
in many ways.
In my least favorite Americans,
huh?
No,
no I'm not.
I'm not talking about the politics or anything else.
I just think,
and here's,
I have a thought about that.
I actually think that they would have benefited a great deal and they're
accomplished.
Don't say slavery.
No,
they would have been
Tom trunk would have been great slave.
Um,
sir.
I think they would have benefited a great deal.
I follow me on this line of logic.
I don't think they've ever been punched in the face well and hard by somebody
who knows how to punch.
And here's what I mean.
The first time I got punched in the face,
I actually got kicked in the head by a black belt and I got knocked out.
It hurts so badly.
I fucking renounced God.
You know,
I was just like thanking God before you go.
No,
but I mean,
in other words,
I was like,
I thought it was the center of the universe and I got kicked in the head and I
fell forward.
I woke up and I was like,
I quit everything.
I don't want my mom and a warm glass of milk and I want a nap.
And it was a seminal moment when I was 18 because I realized I was definitely
not the center of the universe and I was definitely not the tree.
I was just a tiny leaf on a very big tree that um,
you know,
could be plucked very easily.
It was kind of a profound moment cause that kind of pain and that kind of
vulnerability where I realized,
Oh man,
it's easy to kill me.
I heard you don't lie.
Don't Trump has gone through like a ton of,
I don't know,
but he doesn't act like it.
And that's like a successful guy that's rich as fuck and insulated.
That's what he absolutely,
yeah.
And a guy who knows a lot of the people at the top and thinks they're dopes.
He actually had a guy who donated a shit load of money to Hillary Clinton's
campaign so that she came to his fucking wedding and she did.
And she did.
Okay.
So when you recognize that,
then you,
you kind of understand why he acts the way he acts.
He,
if you walked into room feeds,
we talked the king.
If you walked into rueful retards and you got a rifle in your hand and he said,
sit the down.
I'm running this town now.
Okay,
cause you retards had been out shooting my cows and fucking my dog and lightened
my house on fire.
Everybody sit the fuck down.
We'll in a lot of ways to a guy like Donald Trump when he's talking about all
these people in Congress,
didn't know the difference in the Shia and the Sunni.
Yeah.
When he's talking to these people that did make these decisions based on shitty
evidence,
when he's talking about all these fucking people that are secretly playing poker
on their fucking cell phones and they're making gigantic decisions are jerking
off under the table and they get caught.
He knows that he's been around too long.
I'm not saying,
I said,
I hear you saying I don't,
I don't like his arrogance.
I don't like what he said about Mexicans especially.
That's so it's short sided and it's neglecting bullshit.
Building old shit around the center.
Neglecting what?
What's the difference between Mexicans and Americans the first place?
It's just luck.
It's luck and opportunity.
They're all just human beings that got unlucky.
If you were born in fucking war is you would be just like them a fuck so fuck
off.
When when he says that kind of Shit,
especially him,
you got lucky bitch.
Yeah,
you got lucky.
You got lucky.
You weren't born in Tijuana.
If you were,
you'd be just like born to a father who had a lot of money.
That's right.
Son of a bitch,
but that's why he's like,
yes,
this,
what do you think of this?
You know what?
When we a big chief concern,
always an elections as the economy and I'm always fascinated that we never
higher economic studs guys who actually made a lot of money in the economy and
competed.
Instead we hire our government bureaucrats and I don't know what the answer is,
but it seems very counterintuitive for the,
for voters to vote for of say a guy like Barack Obama who actually didn't leave
any,
he never really worked in that.
He was a community organizer.
He never had a real job and then he was,
he went to head kind of okay.
Grades,
I think an Occidental.
And then I think Columbia.
And then he taught at Harvard,
left no academic papers or legacy and then was kind of kind of Greece greased
into the being a senator and didn't leave any legislative legacy.
And you look at the guy and he's a really good speaker and he seems sensible and
fair,
but it's interesting that we voted for him and I voted for him primarily on the
idea that he was black and different and sent a good message to the world are a
thousand reasons,
but I know I wanted to show the world that are,
that we weren't a prejudice nation after the war and that we were a progressive
group of people and that Obama did seem really sensible and they seen fair and
he seem thoughtful.
Um,
so I've kind of,
I'm criticizing myself for this,
but I think it makes sense to vote for somebody sometimes.
Like,
you know,
Republicans make it fucking so hard to vote for him.
But I just feel like if you really care about the economy,
vote for a guy who had to really compete and win in the economy,
they might have a better understanding and perspective.
Right.
But would they be the best qualified dealing with social issues?
I wouldn't be the best qualified to deal with international dilemmas.
Well the international probably,
but social issues,
I think the best way to deal with social issues is to do exactly nothing maybe.
Do you think that it's possible that the whole idea of being a president is just
antiquated?
It's all just some Alpha male primate monkey shit.
We have to have a top dog now because the way the presidency,
the way the,
the our,
our government is organized is fantastic and a lot of ways in terms of the
president still has veto power but needs a two thirds of the majority.
That didn't stop us from going into the Iraq war,
which is what you originally talked about.
Yes,
that's true.
And also if you look at the president,
like if he relies on Congress and Congress realized,
I mean all of those laws that are set up in place to make sure that he doesn't
have like ultimate power can be,
well,
why do I say there in the first place?
Why do we,
why do we have that?
Why do we need one person?
Why is there supposed to be one?
Because,
because ultimately you need one at wet.
Ultimately the responsibility of the president is when you have six different
sources,
the State Department and then intelligent and all these people coming to you
with the options.
You do need a decision maker.
Really.
One guy that seems so good.
One guy still never one guy though.
If he really is that good,
why would he have Joe Biden as a second car?
Stop and think about that.
We'll have Joe Biden's been in government for a very long time.
When you watch the Joe Biden steroid hearings when he's talking about steroids,
when the congressional baseball in Titian,
he's so silly.
Yes.
He's such a silly,
he's considered a blow hard by a lot of people on the other side of the aisle.
Oh Man.
Joe Biden,
if you talk to him,
you talked to anybody who's,
who's been in government a long time.
He's kind of a blowhard.
I mean he's,
he's,
he's a blustery guy.
Silly guy.
Yeah,
you really shouldn't be the top dog for the fucking country,
but he's one heartbeat away.
And being the top dog vice president has always been what your president allows
it to be.
So vice president is typically a ceremonial title where you go to different
ceremonies,
but it's never been,
it's really interesting.
It's an interesting role because it can be a very,
very sort of a morphis vacuous pointless job.
It had been up until Dick Cheney,
it's one of the reasons why Dick Cheney snuck in the puppet master.
He figured out like,
I'll just take this gig that Dan Quayle had,
you know,
I mean,
I'll take this gig that really dumb motherfuckers had except Al Gore.
Al Gore was pretty well respected,
smart guy.
He was respected in some circles.
But Al Gore Gore never had much of a backbone.
Al Gore was always criticized for never really having a strong position on much
so,
but if you look at a guy like a Barack Obama,
what he's like is like a really strong headliner that takes a shitty opening act
with them on the road.
You know,
because if you listen to Joe Biden talk and you know,
he said,
okay,
it's all right.
It just,
it's not offensive to ears.
It's not a terrible speaker.
But then Obama is so good.
He's so,
so,
so powerful.
He,
everything seem some comfortable.
He such a good talker,
but he also,
at the end of the day,
I think,
you know,
he says he's a big free market guy,
but I think Obama really does believe in top down authority.
I do think he really believes that,
um,
ultimately,
uh,
a central group of smart people should be making most of the decisions.
I feel that from him.
Anybody who watches fucking storage wars should think that watching naked and
afraid,
you don't want to,
you don't want to stop these people from making the critical decisions.
But this ward,
this world's fucking future.
Yeah,
you can't,
you can't just have everybody know it.
I mean,
that's a terrible thing to say.
No,
but you can certainly have top down,
you need a federal government,
my God for certain things.
But you also middlee isn't electoral college ultimately.
Isn't that a really fucking scary thing?
And I,
you can decide this is a representative of the state.
So the state votes for representative.
Well,
I'll tell you what I,
I'll tell you what the good side of it is.
What it means that states that have very small populations aren't ignored.
Right?
And that's why they go to Iowa right now.
That's something that you need.
Um,
that's why the politicians go to Iowa.
There's an intelligent argument to get rid of the electoral college.
They fucking dust these farmers off.
They,
they sit them down and they'd say a bunch of bullshit to them.
That's because they believe that arts there and also because the,
they can't read.
So they just let her know that's him.
That's him.
That's a mistake.
A lot of farms or they don't read it all too busy planting rain.
They're picking corn all day.
Got It.
They don't have any time for reading.
Those farmers are actually most of this farmer's smart.
Well there you have to be.
Look,
it's a very,
it's a very tight business.
Like your margins are very small and also there's weirdness like subsidies like
Whoa,
wait a minute.
You few shops.
If it wasn't for subsidies,
there's a lot of farms that would be done of course a long time ago.
And guess who benefits from subsidies?
Huge corporations.
Yeah,
huge factory farms.
Corporations and the corn industry.
There's a book,
there's a fucking fantastic documentary called king corn.
Who?
Cas.
Ooh,
it's fucking nuts man.
These guys,
they set out,
I mean I've mentioned it several times in the podcast,
so I apologize if you've heard this before,
but if you haven't seen it,
just check it out.
The Sky they did,
did do like a,
an analysis of their own bodies and find out what percentage they are.
Of course some ridiculous percentage of all the carbon in their body has come
from corn and then they go through the aisles of the supermarkets and they start
looking at the corn syrup and corn starch and corn,
this accord that,
and you realize how much fucking corn is in everything and huge lobbying efforts
and good for ya.
Now not,
no.
God Damn it makes a state good though.
Yeah.
Do you prefer a grass fed steak?
I like grass fed steak only because only because I just believe there ruminates
I've been told that they're supposed to eat class,
so I liked these in a more natural,
I don't know their tastes,
Becker.
I don't know if it tastes better,
but for me it does,
cause my mind says this is grass fed,
I'm going to be healthier.
They're different.
I wouldn't say I prefer grass,
but there's something about a really nice fatty corn fed ribeye that I
understand.
It's delicious.
100%.
Some of it's really good,
but uh,
it's not good for the animal that's for fuck shore and it's darker meat.
And I got to feel like darker meat is better for you.
I know that's probably not logical,
but the way,
the way the meat,
it's a way of cow.
If a cow eats the way it's biologically supposed to,
I'd imagine that it's probably better for you.
Well,
I feel like that about eggs,
you know.
Um,
sometimes my chickens,
I,
I leave them in the chicken house.
It's a big fucking chicken house.
Just had a chicken die the other day for no reason.
They just die.
His die chicken is out live long.
Well,
I don't know how long they live in a little chicken hearts get out.
Nope.
Nothing happened to it.
It was in the,
in the coupe and the coupe.
It's more,
I call it a coupe,
but it's really a chicken house.
It's big.
Did you check?
It's back for peck marks.
They did peck it depicted as soon as it went down there.
Fucking cannibals as monsters.
They would eat it.
Wow.
They're packed at it.
But it wasn't dead for very long for,
we found it.
Um,
point being when I don't let them out,
their eggs don't taste as good.
The eggs look different,
their eggs become more yellow.
And I buy the best chicken food that you can buy,
the healthiest chicken food you could buy,
but really they want a free range.
And when you let them go and then they run around the yard and they pick grass
and they eat bugs there eggs are much more delicious.
And there were a dark,
dark yolk.
Yeah,
there's a d the other day I took a photo because a,
I was a,
I had eggs and two of them were from an,
uh,
an egg from when they were grazing.
And two were from a little bit later when we had them in the coop for a few
days.
And when they're in that coop,
they're there.
They're fucking eggs come out yellow like supermarket eggs.
Not quite that yellow,
but pretty close.
Whereas otherwise there are dark,
dark orange and they literally taste different.
I got to think they're more nutritious.
I mean,
it only makes sense.
It certainly tastes better.
Your eggs,
I've had x from your,
your coop.
They're amazing,
right?
The Joe Rogan eggs.
Delicious.
You get them the day of like,
I get them in the morning and then I cook them.
I'll have like an egg sandwich for breakfast on some eat chickens and bread.
[inaudible] bread.
Ooh.
Is He keels good stuff with [inaudible].
I like to take the Jalapeno.
Hi.
Then I take some l you could teco or maybe some rochus and I put it over at
fucking sliced Jalapenos on top of being,
you know,
mayonnaise.
I'm not scared of Manet's,
Bro.
Nah,
don't be afraid of Manet's.
Put a little swath.
Fucking work out.
If you want to torture my wife,
you'd give her Manet's and onions mixed in.
She'd throw up immediately.
She doesn't like either one of those like myself,
some Manet's.
She can't look at Manny's really?
What do you do?
You have a food that you can't,
you just can't eat.
No,
I'm a man.
Jesus.
Fuck is wrong with you.
Okay.
What do you have any rain?
So,
because I've eaten brains before,
not main lambs brains.
I want any tongue.
Her brain's really,
I'm not crazy about kidney and slides that it's just,
I don't like the texture of tar.
Yeah.
Choose none and make the tongue.
Kosher tongue.
Cow Tongue ever had it?
Hmm.
No,
I did have it as a kid and I said,
this looks like a tongue.
And my grandfather said it's not a tongue.
And I got,
it looks like tongue.
I was in Greece and I ate it and I was like,
fucking Tom.
It was Tom.
It,
I never read it again.
When we were in Montana and we ate that deer skull.
You didn't eat name that deer tongue when they chopped up the deer tone.
But I eyeball,
I remember when I ate,
I,
Steve gave me the fat behind the eye ball.
It was raw and I ate that.
Yeah.
What was that called again?
Talo.
Yeah.
It takes so choosy.
Chewy,
chewy.
Yeah.
I didn't need it.
I saw you eating it.
It was disgusting.
I was calmer and then I ate the ravine.
Calmer.
Makes me sad to this day.
Yeah.
Because,
uh,
one of the funniest things that happened on the trip with Brian and I when we
went to Montana with Steve Rinella and crew is it Brian created a character
called the ravine calmer where I was going to come in and it has only been a few
times in my life where I almost blacked out from laughing because that was one
of them.
But you're never going to see it.
You never get to see it.
Cause that's fucking good old fashion outdoorsman sportsmen's channel.
You know,
we choose this and we're out there hunting part of it.
It's,
I like to do it to you guys like Steve and,
and Dan Dougherty who,
who don't know what to do when I go,
hey,
is anybody using this ravine?
If not,
I'm going to come in it.
You might have a come in the ravine where you started getting angry and yelling
at,
I checked off my,
if I didn't really hear Jack off,
kept talking about being the ravine calmer and you had to be there.
But the point being is like,
it's not a lot of our ridiculous silliness.
We'll never make it on his show.
No.
So we're doing this amazing performance for like,
you're doing it more than I am.
You're,
yeah.
I'm not that kind of your different kind of on than I am.
You know,
when we go to these things,
it's one of the reasons why I love having you around because you just love
making everybody laugh.
You love making me laugh to hear everything in the world.
Yeah,
you're,
you're just reduced weekend.
I made somebody laugh for one hour,
the groom of the wedding and I,
and this is so sick,
but I made him laugh.
I've never made anybody laughed at heart for what?
I did,
an hour of material and it was all,
his son is a really good looking 17 year old.
The rest are really muscular and really smooth.
Oh,
this is us were Turkey hunting?
Is this a,
it's a short clip from a,
let's play it.
Let's wait.
Hold on my story.
Please play it.
Let's hear it.
Cool.
Okay.
All right.
Walk.
Yas.
Sportsmans channel network.
Okay,
well let's let it load up.
We had just leave it right there.
We had a good fucking time though,
Matt.
It was a good time to time.
Turkey hunting though is for the birds.
Yeah.
Here's what the problem with Turkey hunting.
If you love Turkey hunting,
I appreciate it.
Absolutely.
I get it.
I,
I shot a Turkey.
We ate some of it.
It was delicious Turkey.
Yeah.
Get this all like the call on the moon,
but trying to locate,
I was asleep and snoring and Steven knows like you're sleeping on it.
Didn't know.
It wasn't like lying down snoring.
Well you wake me up.
I will fucking tell you I wasn't sleeping automatically.
Yeah.
What is it about that?
It's like that vulnerable feeling.
Like I'm,
I'm awake.
It's embarrassing.
I W I S L I wasn't sure.
I was sure that I was awake,
man.
I slept nine hours of time and I kept it a secret from my wife and I'm like,
where are we?
Where are you?
I go,
I was in the garage.
I liked her.
I go,
I was working out in the,
uh,
I was sleeping for two hours and I lied.
I lied right to her.
Like I was like,
Nah,
I was in my office working out.
We need a hunting show where we do it online with nobody sponsoring it.
Nobody.
Like we're just,
we do it the same way we have done with podcasts.
Yeah,
we need that.
I need to just finance it and I'll just hire some dude to just film us.
We'll take someone like Brian Callahan or something like that.
Take us hunting somewhere and we'll just film.
It wasn't just first how much [inaudible] costs.
I mean how much could it really possibly cost if we just had like a sponsor like
rifles that we use or you know,
products that we use like Hoyt bows or something like that.
Just a sponsor that it could help us defer some of the costs of production.
It would be so much fun because these,
these trips,
like the trip that we had when we went out to a Alaska and we went into the
Prince Edward Island,
fucking fantastic time.
Horrible rains we were talking about earlier with like fun.
That's like fun logging hours,
doing it alone.
It was terrible.
Like we're soaking wet the entire trip.
It was,
it never stopped raining.
If it would stop,
it stopped for like 20 minutes that we shoot.
Like some video footage of us being out there for 20 minutes and looking for
deer that we never found right.
And then he'll go right back to raining.
It was horrible,
but we had so many fucking laughs.
Just the time that we were in the trailer or the the tent rather the grants and
we had one,
one indication of that is the podcast that we did from there.
Steve's podcast,
which was one of the best ones that we did.
You know one of Steve's that we did where it's not censored,
like unlike the show,
it's completely free.
So we're there just to listen to the laughing.
We were giving him so much shit about his shit collection.
Remember Steve Rinella has,
he's so fucking into wildlife.
This dude had a stool collection of all the various animals that he had hunted.
He had like bear shit,
duck Shisha Steve,
a picture of shit in the wild and he'll be like,
ah,
that's,
that's record.
I did.
I told them there was a fucking animal that was trying to get into my chicken
coop and it's shit in my yard.
I sent him a picture of it.
He said it was a skunk.
Wow.
Yeah,
I see.
It was a fucking skunk outcomes.
These countries skunks,
skunks will kill the fuck out of your chickens.
Skunks are Predator.
Oh,
hey.
All right.
Yup.
Yeah.
Sculpture predators.
That's amazing.
They'll eat birds.
Oh yeah.
Especially chickens.
They were trying to get to my chicken.
How about Rick Collins?
Oh really?
Yeah.
Raccoons with Alex.
You're a forest grass.
You better run.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Do Ground nesting birds.
I said about Turkey.
He's,
everybody's trying to kill Turkeys all the time.
Turkey's die all the time.
A three year old Turkey's hold.
Well,
when we were Turkey hunting,
we shot a Turkey.
Oops.
Spoiler alert.
But we only shot one.
It was a young,
stupid Turkey.
It's called a Jake.
I shot it.
Yeah.
And I'm Brian's Day.
When I was snoring,
Brian,
Brian couldn't fucking find a Turkey.
We couldn't find a Turk.
Gay told me Chris did a rock,
paper,
scissors.
I won.
So I got to shoot first.
Yeah,
so you use a lot of times you should have done we bullshit shot at the same time
cause three fucking turkeys came in.
We should,
we should have said I agree.
Let's do this.
Oh God.
Three we should,
we could have both had turkeys we thought since that was the first day book.
Ah,
we're going to see a bunch of Turkeys.
This is awesome.
Yeah.
No it wasn't.
No,
it was a bunch of time.
Sit around and Napa Valley.
Okay.
We're not pretending.
We're in Alaska.
We're not in the fall.
We went to eat at fantastic restaurants every night I want to be at Bu Shawl.
Those dummies.
They fucking eat cheeseburgers and shit.
I'm like,
come on,
take you to the restaurant.
I'm going to pay.
Let's go.
But we're going to go book the hose,
drink beer,
best food in the world.
Like literally the best restaurants in the world.
And Rinella never joined us once I took fuck.
He likes to pretend he's in the woods.
He doesn't like the fact that he has it gets to stay in a house when he hunts.
Oh,
he wants to suffer.
He wants to live in the,
in the dirt.
So the fact that we were going to go and drink fine wine and eat duck,
we ate grilled duck in Philemon.
Y'All,
we had,
there was a,
a potato puree took me a half hour to find the wine I wanted to,
I love that wonderful place.
But we,
uh,
we treated it differently than them.
They did not want to admit that they were staying in a house in Napa Valley
while they were doing that show.
They're pretending that they're out there in the woods,
Turkey hunting.
You're in a guy's yard.
You're in it.
You're shooting a fucking bird that I could buy down the store.
And here's the problem.
He fucked up when he cooked his Turkey breast.
Cause you know what,
that Turkey breast tastes just like the stuff I buy this car,
like fucking Turkey breasts.
No,
no,
no.
God Damn,
this is going to be the best trick in the world.
No,
nope.
Pretty fucking boring.
You guys stay here.
I'll go to the Deli and have the same experience.
And you know,
I guess the legs tastes a little better.
I need to cook.
You know,
that's what come over.
Come over this week man.
And I'll cook uh,
some Turkey and some Moose.
All right.
Cause the Turkey that we shot,
I have that have most of it except I'm around them all.
We ate one breast,
one,
one breast.
Let's do it tomorrow.
One fucking breast while we were there.
And we were like,
okay,
it tastes like he made Schnitzel.
You know,
like I've tried to write it or I do my podcast called the fighter and the kid
can use it in here.
That shows picked up by Fox.
That's some crazy deal.
She's crazy.
Deal with Fox sports.
How about this?
We sold out.
Whoa.
I'm waiting for someone to come along with enough money for me to sell out.
Did we sold,
we sold the prey.
Oh you mean the show podcast out six weeks in advance.
The brand promise.
And by the way,
everybody,
10:00 PM prof,
November 12th,
we're going to do a live,
I like come on your life podcast in Tempe.
What Day is the one you did in uh,
October 1st.
[inaudible] on that fucker off.
Yeah.
You're more than welcome to him on that,
but are you kidding?
I'm going to be on it.
That'd be great.
I'm going have a good time.
Uh,
I didn't do it high as fuck though.
We're going to get tired of you guys talking sober.
Hey man,
come on.
Really don't push your drugs on me.
Loves me.
I think I'm going to get Brandon to do some standup.
He's definitely should do still.
Yeah.
He died July podcasts.
I want them to do three,
four minutes.
He should do it.
He could,
he could do it on a,
every time I do in the UFC,
he could definitely do it on dating Ronda.
But you shouldn't tell him not to.
He won't.
No,
he doesn't.
She's tired of taking shit for just saying anything.
Yeah.
Let it go,
man.
In the podcast he goes,
just so you know,
I am never talking about that shit again.
He's just so sick and she's the queen of the world.
Got To let it go.
She's bigger than Oprah,
but he has a lot of guy.
He doesn't,
he's never said a bad thing about her and his life.
Well,
he does love her.
He does care about her.
It didn't work out.
I've never heard that guy say one thing besides that.
She's great and I'm not even proud.
There was the one time on the podcast where he said that he's too much of a man.
He just meant he meant with Rhonda.
It's either you are going to be taking a back seat to,
she's driving the train or you need the exactly the extreme opposite that.
That's what I think he was trying to say.
He didn't mean too much.
He's just not,
he's a,
he's a strong personality.
She's a strong personality that that tends to be hard to diminish.
But I'm fucking anyway,
come see us November to change the subject.
I like how you wanted to keep going,
so see the fighter and the kid.
Well you and I really need to do is we need to do a show where it's just us
doing whatever the fuck we want to do and turn it into funny.
It's like,
I want you to be on the audience.
I'll be your audience that come with you.
We'll do things together.
Most of it is like me setting you up most of the meeting or show the fun stuff
is me setting you up and you knock it out of the park.
Right over and over and over again.
Right?
But it's,
we have a weird dynamic.
It was really funny.
And Rinella.
We,
we,
we talked about it before,
like we were really bored at one time.
He goes,
man,
he goes,
uh,
I wish Kevin was here right now.
I go,
yeah,
if he was here,
it'd be like really fun.
He goes,
no offense.
I go,
no,
it's enough.
I'm not funny like that.
I'm a different guy.
I mean,
occasionally I'm funny like that.
Yeah,
but not like you can't count on it.
Now I'm a jackass.
I only have fun when I'm being a jackass like that.
I just,
I'm,
I'm looking for any opening.
You're talking,
I'm not even listening.
I'm like,
where's the worst I can give a fuck what you're saying.
Isn't that a problem when you're doing a podcast?
I,
of course,
the problem with my life,
I've never serious,
but it's not necessarily a problem.
When we do stuff like that,
fucking works for stand up,
do it.
It definitely works for standing up,
but it also works for doing that hunting thing.
We've got to talk to her.
Know about that.
Let's do it.
Say,
listen.
You can see he,
I briefly talked to him and his company.
We talked about me doing a show and I was really considering it,
but first of all,
I don't,
there's a lot of shit that I take from hunting that for no reason.
It's so silly.
I take it from people that have dogs and cats and they're fucking Instagram
page.
I got into it with this lady.
She's a very nice lady.
She's a tattoo artist.
She gave me a hard time about calling a hunting a ethically retarded or
something like that and then I went to her page.
It's just got animals.
I'm like,
come on.
You feed your animals,
murdered animals.
It's the only way you're going to keep them things alive.
If you have dogs and a cat,
what do you feed him?
She admitted,
she goes,
yes,
it's not,
it's like a necessary evil.
And you know,
it was a very friendly exchange cause she had beautiful artwork.
She's a really talented tattoo artist.
I go,
come on,
this is silly.
Like the these does,
you're not getting this from the dog food tree.
You're going to have your horse mate from that and from cows and byproducts and,
and guts and feet and all kinds of shit.
They grind up and lamb,
which is basically baby sheep and the chickens,
they fucking grind chickens up and compress them into cat food.
I mean that's what it is.
And those animals are not happy and their will a real living thing.
If I shoot a moose or whatever the fuck I shoot,
that's,
I'm eating that whole God damn thing.
And uh,
it's one animal.
And that's one of the things that I like about hunting a large animal like that
as opposed to like a Turkey.
If you shoot a Turkey,
it's only going to live if it's only going to feed like a few people,
like a Turkey will feed five people like that Turkey,
we shot five people and having a meal and it's over.
But it's also this,
I mean,
you know that what I always say is even trophy hunting,
which I don't do it,
but even trophy hunting is the revenue from those kinds of hunts.
I honestly hate that argument and I really want to talk to hunter's about not
using it because it's true.
It is true,
but it's so fucked up that it's true that it's more just economy.
It's economics is economics,
but it's,
here's the deal,
right?
If you're,
if you love something,
whether it's a elephants or rhinos,
you love some exotic,
crazy animal that we don't have in North America and you,
you,
you want to pay a lot of money to shoot it and you're not even going to eat it.
I guess they do eat elephants.
Um,
which I didn't know till I was part of getting into,
but I guess,
I guess it tastes good,
man.
It's fucked because they're,
they're intelligent and they're not traditionally family structures and all that
great memories.
They remember family members from like 20 years ago.
They reunite them,
they hug like it's,
it's trippy man.
I've seen a video of a mother and a child reunited after 20 years and they're
hugging like we don't think anything of a child leaving a family.
Cause that's what we do.
You know,
if you live with your house,
your family and your 40 or fucking loser.
Yeah.
But if you're an elephant and you're,
you're,
you know,
you have children's children's stay near you.
I was like this structure,
that's their natural structure.
We don't think anything of like separating them,
taking them off here,
taking them off there.
It's one of the most damning things about something like seaworld,
like that they have the balls to have these commercials where they say we
haven't taken an animal from the wild and 35 years.
That's like a Puran having slaves saying we haven't kidnapped this person from
their family in another country in 35 years.
So this is okay that we keep slaves.
Cause that's what Orca is.
When an Orca or a dolphin,
they're fucking slaying.
See Black Fish.
Cause I,
I find it too upset and he'll drive you crazy.
It would drive you crazy.
It doesn't matter what they say.
There's,
there's no getting away from the fact those animals are kept it cause a
psychosis.
Yes.
There's all sorts of problems with them,
but there's just no getting away from the fact they're captive.
You're not talking about a dog man.
My dog got upset today because I was on the other side of the fence and I was
having a phone call and he's pawing at the door.
He wants to get to me.
Come on man,
hang out with me.
I'm like,
dude,
I'm on the phone.
I'm not patching a minute right now I'm on the phone and he has a j you see my
dogs yard shy.
It's an acre.
He just wants to be part of you.
Exactly.
And they don't want to be captive.
They want to be free to do whatever they want.
And this is a dog who lives in a family.
I mean,
he's one of the family domestic animals.
Domesticated.
He's a sweetie.
He's one of the family.
You know,
he lives in the house.
He sleeps in the house.
He's just outside doing his shame and he doesn't like it.
Let me out,
bitch.
Come on.
What is this?
Imagine the madness.
If you are a person and you were forced to live in an empty tank or an empty
swimming pool like imagine if you in the same structure where an Orca lives.
That's your world.
How much room do they have?
Not much at all because you know what's really terrifying.
There's a photo of the seaworld parking lot.
It shows the parking lot,
and that shows where the Orca enclosure is in relationship to the size of the
parking lot.
It's fucking terrifying.
It's terrifying.
Tiny little thing.
Just imagine if you had to live in a drain pool,
essentially.
That's why it's a form of torture.
It is a form of torts that solitary confinement and you know the really crazy
animal rights activists believe that you shouldn't own any pets.
That I shouldn't even have my dog.
I shouldn't have my cats dogs.
Especially our domesticated.
There's a difference in a wild animals tame and that domesticated animal,
well,
my cat's Prudy fucking domesticated life seeing grounds.
We've seen fluff at five of the fuck this fucking rag doll in the morning.
Okay.
We have to be really quiet in the morning because the cat will hear your voice
and start me out.
One of the door just to come in and get pal and you see her as soon as you see
her,
she's like,
she immediately starts parents.
She wants,
Oh yeah,
she wants you to pick her up.
She goes limp.
And it's the most domesticated animal ever.
Anybody that wants that poor thing to fend for itself is a fucking crazy person.
This is,
this is a baby.
The dogs are pack animals.
Two dogs want to be,
I'm imagining the cats have a pride,
but dogs definitely want to be part of,
uh,
you know,
my cats.
I've uh,
the male and the female.
I had a cat just die.
She was 13 years old.
It was pretty sad or not 13.
Excuse me.
She was 19,
19 years old when she died.
Um,
but the other one is a seven and I'm the baby.
The new one is 10 months old,
I guess.
Maybe 11 months old now.
Yeah.
I think she was born October,
so she's a fucking baby still and she's like this little fluffy fur.
It's like the difference between her and an animal in the wild is so far removed
so many generations that it's a really odd that we do that to those things.
Yeah.
You know,
they make awesome pets,
but it's really odd that we choose to make an English bulldog that's,
that's sensing
fucking flat face.
You ever see him try to breathe?
They overheat.
I'm like,
what did we do?
Or someone does something mean you?
What did someone do that made that thing?
Well,
that just played with genes that that whole movement happened.
When was that?
In the 1920s or when we're home,
we started changing dogs.
Well,
I think they've done it.
You'd like to a certain extent through the history of dog breeding.
I think it's existed for a long time,
but not to the level that they've done now where they make like Pekinese and
these special breeds.
And I saw a guy the other day that had two wolves.
He was walking,
he reading,
reading tweets.
You shut the goddamn phone.
I go to a dare.
Just see to look that up.
The other thing we were talking thought though,
you're reading tweets,
tweets to fuck the police.
His guy was walking in the street.
There's the seaworld parking lot.
It's in the green.
So that green is the tank and the rest is the parking lot.
That's the Orkin closure.
Oh No.
Yeah,
it's horrible.
It's horrific.
Wow.
So this guy was walking with wolves.
He had pet wolves and you could tell right away it was a really weird,
they were really cold.
Oh God.
Yeah.
Beautiful.
They're fucking horrifying.
They're horrifying.
But they're beautiful.
Do Wolves to me.
Um,
I like this amazing creature that is,
you know,
I respect them deeply.
I love like what they represent.
I love looking at them,
but they feel like a trap man.
I think the love that some people have for animals in this really distorted
perception of what a,
a Predator like a wolf truly is,
has allowed people to import these things and put them into Idaho and all these
different areas.
And I'm reading all these stories about what's going on now,
how they're decimating the elk populations and people really terrified of him.
And when I was in British Columbia and uh,
I was up there with my friend Mike,
who was a,
a business up there,
have a guide business and he has a farm his fucking neighbors do.
They had a cow that was killed in the middle of the night by wolves.
Yeah.
Like they came in and kill the cow like 20 of them.
The problem with wolves is that there a,
you talked to any farmer,
any rancher,
why do they hate wolfs and this is the world over,
what has it been,
have have it like in Sweden,
they're reintroducing the wolves.
It's really controversial because the people that make their living off their
livestock,
fucking wolves are such efficient killers and keeping them out is basically,
it's really,
really hard.
So smart.
They're so smart.
They act together as a reason that farmers traditionally when after wolves right
away,
like whether it was in Italy and Sweden,
anywhere there,
there's no real society that didn't go after wolves because they were so
devastating to your crops.
We've,
we've gone so far away from recognizing that and remembering that,
that people have brought these things back in some sort of a weird attempt to
balance the ecosystem.
And when,
when they open hunting seasons,
there's all these protests and the protests are almost invariably from people
that live in the cities.
That's the issue with the difference of Vancouver in British Columbia being a
province.
Like the people in Vancouver,
they're all liberal.
It's like it's a beautiful place to live.
There's no wolves here,
man.
Don't go killing wolves.
But the people who live where Michael,
you can kill as many wolves a day as you want.
Yeah.
Because then you can't,
you can never get rid of all.
Exactly.
They're really hard to find or they're elusive.
Ran into this guy at the airport and,
um,
he was really smart guy,
really smart guy,
and really articulate guy up in Canada and,
um,
ask me question,
you know,
what are you here for?
Blah,
blah,
blah.
I forget what he told me his business was.
I probably wouldn't say it anyway.
Somehow or another people would figure out who it is.
But he was,
uh,
it was talking to me about his business.
We were talking a little bit and he asked me when I was up here for,
and I told them I was up there for a hunting trip and then he started talking to
me about how much he hunts wolves.
Like right away he goes into this.
Yeah,
we,
uh,
we hunt wolves all the time and he goes,
you got to,
I own a piece of property up there and we've seen them chase down,
uh,
calves and kill them.
He goes,
we've seen it.
And he goes,
we've seen the wolves he goes to,
they're just,
there's so many of them that what we do is they take garbage bails,
like a big garbage pail and they fill it with meat and then they pour water into
a,
the garbage pail.
So it's filled to the top with water and meet.
Then they freeze it and once they freeze it,
then they take it and they put it out like a popsicle.
Wow.
And then the wolves can't take it all at once.
So they'll definitely keep coming to it.
So they get a little bit of the meat and I'll come back from war and they got to
chew through the ice and there's meat inside the ice and then they'll shoot them
and he said,
you,
he goes,
we shoot them all year long.
We have to shoot him as many,
as many as we can.
I've heard the,
the um,
we didn't even reality,
the end unit used to take as well as just such a nightmare for them.
It's still their food,
their seal at nights of that.
And they would put a razor blade,
like a knife with a piece of meat on it and the wolf would eat the meat and then
lik to the blade,
cut themselves up and die.
They would,
uh,
yeah,
they would put blood on,
uh,
on,
on keep licking their on blood and knife,
razor sharp knife.
Yeah.
It was terrifying.
Oof
Our square to list those worlds,
man.
That's those worlds.
I really think that there's a certain amount of struggle,
like you said,
a certain amount of losing makes you more humble and respectful.
And like what you were talking about where a guy like Donald Trump,
it's all this sort of conversation is all coming around in this morning.
We do here,
you know,
but it really isn't this one.
It's like,
and what we were talking about about academia,
about,
uh,
the,
the cowardice of this new way of pushing,
feeling,
feeling something,
hit,
hitting a wall is very important.
And their thought bullies who thought bullies about it and what we'll,
we're,
where's that all coming from?
Well,
I mean,
it really is coming from the,
so there's a lack of real world experience at a lack of adversity.
The adversity has only been electrical diversity.
So this adversity rather.
So there's these conversations.
They're having the battles that are going on there.
There were about ridiculous shit.
They're not about survival.
There are about calling someone z or he,
and there's anger and there's rhetoric and there's protests.
And then there's this like there's this crazy need to control what the other
people think and what is acceptable and not acceptable on my fucking campus.
Have you ever seen the Toronto protests?
Somebody's sensibilities is sacred.
Ever seen the Toronto protest where these feminists,
uh,
there was some guy who was promoting something about something that had to do
with men's rights.
They completely distorted what he had to say,
completely distorted what his message was and promoted him as this like evil
person who supported rape and hated women.
And so they shut down his,
uh,
his performance that by turning on a fucking fire extinguisher fire alarm,
they set off a fire alarm and all cheered.
They were protesting in the hallways.
While this guy's on stage speaking.
Sure.
That's not surprising.
It's,
it's a,
it's a hostile act.
It's a controlling act.
It's exactly what the Red Guard did in Mao's China.
And there are a thousand examples of people that get swept away with an
ideology.
These are very religious people and by that I mean they're fanatically devoted
to what they think is a certain truth or set of truisms and they'll do whatever
they can.
Well,
that's why it's important what you're saying because they'll do whatever they
can to,
but what,
it's not based on his reality.
So like if there really was a person that was at this campus that was promoting
raping women and,
and,
and doing horrible things to them and this is what you should do and he's trying
to rally them up.
Absolutely everyone agrees they should be treated the way these women were
treating that guy.
The question is,
is what he's promoting that or are you turning it into that in order to make it
justifiable for you to go fucking crazy?
Because that's what a lot of it is.
What a lot of it is.
People decide they have a target and then justify their actions based on that.
Also they decide they shoot their guns at the wrong target.
Uh,
because it's an easy target.
And that's an important point though in their defense.
I mean if someone really is promoting rape,
fuck that guy.
Right,
right.
So that would be a realistic reason to use that target for what you're saying
it.
So they make them that they make,
they distort what he is and they turned them into that.
So then it's justifiable.
Yes.
And the women were screaming,
get these men that were trying to go in and listen.
All they wanted to do was hear what this guy had to say.
Screaming ethic,
you fucking piece of shit.
You support rape.
Like what are you talking about?
But this,
this anger and violence and vitriol gives them a cause.
People want to,
cause there's no diversity.
I want to feel like they're,
they're revolutionaries.
There is no,
there's not enough diversity with healthy.
It's not healthy.
It's also not,
it's not honest.
I don't think they're being honest with themselves or with,
with what the real problem is.
And that's another issue is that if you,
if you're too ideological and religious,
you're going to be placing your energy and your anger in the wrong direction and
there are real challenges and problems and it takes so birth thought,
Soper thought sober analysis and an open mind to finding out and developing a
very informed point of view so that then you can actually tackle what's really
going on.
So good luck finding someone else who also taking the same amount of
consideration into a subject and has an approach to it with some intense bias.
Exactly.
So having these debates,
these people,
it's like there's this bridges you can't cross.
There's things that you can't say.
Well,
there's very important though.
Now when you have a debate,
and I'll give you an example,
very important in my opinion,
the problem with debate in this country is this.
Let's take gun control as an example.
The first thing you hear is,
I'm in favor of guns.
I'm not in fear,
I'm in favor of gun control.
But when you actually hear,
when they started,
the debate is this,
you're a gun nut and I don't like you.
You're a hippie liberal and you don't know what this country was founded on and
that's where we start in the minute that happens,
there is no way anybody's going to have a discussion because it starts with I
don't like you.
Oh yeah,
I don't like you.
Instead of instead of saying,
hey guys,
we're,
we're both good people who have a different point of view and we're trying to
solve a problem.
Nobody in this room thinks that somebody should be allowed to go on and
massacre,
uh,
a school or a movie theater.
We know we want to solve that problem.
Now this side believes everybody should have guns.
This side believes they shouldn't.
Where is the middle ground?
Let's have a real discussion.
It never starts that way.
Unfortunately.
A lot of times it just becomes this crazy sort of,
uh,
this is my camp,
this is my idea and I'm more and more interested in being right based on my
ideology.
That's immovable and it's very difficult.
It's very difficult to kind of step back and be sober in these thoughts,
at least in these situations.
For example,
like like gun control.
It's interesting because when this guy came up and shot these two reporters and,
and this psychiatrist happened recently and a psychiatrist,
I think his name is Lieberman,
Jeff Lieberman,
anything cause he's out of Columbia University.
He said something really and probably a black guy,
right?
He was a black guy.
[inaudible] he has Jeff Lieberman now Julie writes,
he's Jewish.
I knew it.
You guests.
Good guess,
good guess.
But he had something really interesting to say and it was a really interesting
debate I'd never heard before.
He said,
look,
um,
mental illness,
there is an idea that may be if somebody is exhibiting psychotic behavior and
talking about wanting to hurt other people in himself.
A lot of people who have mental illness are not willing to take their drugs
because they don't think there's anything wrong with them.
So how do you deal with that?
Well,
he said,
what about,
what about in some instances,
outpatient care that is mandated and we'll
wait a minute.
That's that steps on my civil rights.
You can't tell me to take drugs.
And he said,
but wait,
if you have tuberculosis,
you are mandated by the Center for Disease Control to take your drugs because
you're contagious and you're not allowed to not take antibiotics when you have a
tuberculosis.
And usually it's a nine month regimen.
It can turn you color blind.
Like I did my buddy Jimmy Burke and all that.
But what about,
what about,
what about those questions?
What about stuff that kinda throws things in the air?
A Hey,
you just filled me with a cloud of whatever.
Trying to give you contact.
Know those are,
those are important questions to raise men.
They are,
I didn't know Jimmy Burke went colorblind.
Yeah.
From his antibiotic regimen.
Fuck yeah.
He's color blind now.
And what is that from?
What disease was it?
He had tuberculosis and so it just,
the antibiotics just killed it forever.
Yeah.
Whoa.
But he had to take them.
So what do you think if somebody,
if somebody is saying I want to kill people and he's just saying it's illness
and I think it is a good idea to treat it as it is an illness.
And the problem with the mental illness stigma and Kara Santa Maria who's been
on this podcast a bunch of times,
she's a neuroscientist,
very smart,
and she's had mental illness issues herself with depression,
which is also a mental illness.
So not well.
We treat them differently than we treat any other illness.
Like if you,
there's no shame in having a diabetes,
you know,
we find out that you have a disease and we don't go fuck a diabetes Bro.
Like it's a disease.
So we treat it with medics,
medicine,
you know,
same thing with virtually every disease except mine diseases.
And when someone doesn't mind disease,
we automatically assume that they're being weak.
We automatically put them into this box,
oh,
you're depressed.
I'll pour fucking baby.
Think going to be fine,
dude,
we're going to be here.
You're happy.
You're a fucking bored.
And the 16 hundreds you know,
there's all the nonsense that comes with people admitting that there's a
chemical imbalance in their brain,
which we,
we can't really measure.
That's the problem.
They can't fucking,
they can't just pull the juice out of your brain and measure you for depression.
You know,
and they can't really measure,
like there's no like scale to chose what drug is going to work for you.
Right.
Which is one of the weirdest things about taking antidepressants,
but whatever the,
whatever the case there,
it's some form of medication for a disease.
And when someone doesn't want to take that medication,
this is one of the episodes,
the episode I was talking about of called elements on,
um,
uh,
radio lab that was talking about lithium.
This woman who can't take this medication and,
but once she takes it,
she's her,
he,
she,
it is a mental illness.
She has mental illness being bipolar.
It's an absolute disease.
And when she takes this stuff,
she's totally normal.
So this idea that we have about medication when it comes to mental illness,
I think it's the one illness that we have this like criticism of,
or this prejudice of that we could just do because it's hard to measure.
Yes.
Yeah.
And,
and who decides and there are,
there is criteria and there is,
there are experts that can say,
I think in some instances,
hey,
this dude is exhibiting classic psychotic behavior and he's going to hurt
somebody.
And I think it would behoove the authorities to mandate some kind of a drug
regimen or something.
Now this is really know when to say it though.
Nice guy would that hasn't done anything yet.
He just seems a little off.
You don't know what it is.
Right?
It's dicey.
It's a very,
very tricky stuff because now you're talking about a government agency coming in
there and making you take drugs.
Yeah.
Um,
but in some instances it might save a lot of lives if you've got a crazy person.
And the question becomes what if that is a viable alternative to having people
get shot up in some instances?
What do you do about it?
If it's a really good question and a really hard one to answer because here's,
here's another factor.
When you experiment,
when you do an experiment,
the fact that you're doing an experiment has a,
an,
it has an effect on the results of the experiment itself.
A classic one that we've talked about on this podcast for thing was Carl Hart
that brought this up,
a brilliant point that I'd never even considered.
They'd always talk about these things that they do with rats.
You know,
they give rats a heroine and the rats.
So I do the heroin every day and then,
you know,
they can't do on their tasks,
but if you give them cocaine,
they just do cocaine until they die.
When he goes,
yeah,
but they're in a cage during an experiment.
This isn't a normal rat change.
It's changed the rat cage changed the entire extra drugs.
You can't just,
it's not like you're giving them cocaine in the woods.
Well,
if you did that,
you would have like much more reasonable results.
Do you know what the results were as fascinating?
So they laced the,
the water with cocaine and heroin.
The rats kept doing it until they died.
And then this experiment came along and said,
why don't we change the rat cage?
I'll create rat Disneyland and the rat.
He created a,
a utopia for rats.
They had plenty of sex friends play with lots of things to keep themselves
occupied.
Do you know how many rats kept going back to the cocaine and heroin bottle?
None.
After awhile they,
from what I,
from what I was told,
the experiment yielded no addiction and they all started drinking water and went
back and they kind of said,
I'm done with that drug thing.
So one changes things up.
We'll also,
okay,
let's think about that for a second.
Because if we're living the way we're living today,
it's because people before us have figured out how to build houses and
electricity and cars,
but how many generations,
how many generations in relationship to the DNA that's in our body that's
supposedly takes like 10,000 plus years to to change or I mean how,
how similar are we to people that live 10,000 years ago?
Probably almost exactly.
Are really a logic.
Really,
really,
really fucking close,
right?
Maybe the reason why people were into drugs and constantly trying to alter the
state of their consciousness today is directly connected to these rats.
Being willing to do this experiment or be willing to go back to the cocaine
until he fucking died in this experiment as opposed to where they were in the
wild.
Like maybe if we were living in the wild,
maybe if we lived the way live thousands of years ago,
it's a hunter gatherers.
Maybe if we did that,
we would have no desire to do coke.
I would agree with you if I didn't know that pygmies in certain parts of the
Congo smoke copious amounts of weed.
Yes they do.
And if people in the Amazon who are hunter gatherers take all kinds of,
yeah,
I'll just stop and think about the drugs that you just described.
Copious amount of weed,
which makes them more sensitive,
more paranoid,
maybe keeps them alive,
more,
more community oriented,
more loving and may be even more creative.
So you're talking about marijuana.
If you're talking about the people that live in the indigenous tribes in the
Amazon,
you're talking about serious psychedelic drugs that are ego dissolving,
that removed the world around you and bond you inexorably as this tribe.
So you're not talking about heroin and not talking about coke,
especially not talking about coke,
like how many fucking people they do.
They do chew coca leaves and a lot of those,
uh,
those environments,
in fact in Peru.
Yeah.
But it's,
coca leaves got as well and,
and that Ethiopia and places,
God is a,
but that's more,
isn't that more like a narcotics and narcotic?
Yeah,
but the,
the coca leaves apparently it's really nice.
It's really nice.
It's God keeps you mellow or is it,
does it own hype you up?
I think it's a stimulant.
I think.
I think that's a shitload of it.
In the Middle East.
I remember it as a kid.
Yeah.
I wonder if,
uh,
we went back to living this sort of subsistence life.
If,
if any of that stuff would have any pull on us at all.
I don't know.
But I do think that the new science of like Portugal decriminalized all drugs,
all drugs.
And what they did is really interesting thing.
They think by some measures in 2000,
uh,
1% of the population was hooked on heroin,
which is incredible,
huge addiction issue.
And you have to be careful with these statistics.
But this is what I heard on ted.com and when the government said,
I'll tell you what,
instead of spending all his money on enforcement and Rehab and stuff,
we'll,
we'll take,
addicts will decriminalize it.
And what Addicks need is connection.
So what we'll do is we'll say,
well,
we'll get them in rehab and we'll take care of that.
And then we'll get them a job and we'll say to their employer,
look,
train this guy.
We'll pay,
we'll pay half their wages.
Uh,
it'll cost you half as much to hire this addict who is going to take your
program.
We have our own programs.
They're managing their addiction and they've had huge success because what
happens to the addict is that they develop connections and they develop a
purpose and to develop,
uh,
you know,
an an entire infrastructure of support around them.
And that apparently from what I understand,
a lot of like addiction specialists talk about that being very important man
connection is,
is a great anecdote or antidote to your,
your addiction issues.
Um,
I'm not an addiction.
Yeah,
I'm not either.
I think one of the big problems with addiction specialists in this country is
they're only allowed to use methods outside of drugs.
There's a,
there's some people that get some spectacular results and other countries,
especially in Mexico with Ibogaine or people that are hooked on pills,
I've again,
I began is a,
it's from the Boga plant and it's,
um,
it's really intensely introspective drug that is a,
it's not a fun time at all.
There's very,
very little recreational ibogaine cause,
just like really intense,
um,
view of your life.
Very,
very deep and complex view of your life.
And it also shuts off some physical reactions to addiction somehow or another
rewires the mind.
Some strange way that's very,
very effective.
I've had friends that have had pill problems that have gone to these retreats in
Mexico and that Ibogaine treatment and just completely knocked it out.
How much they just placebo.
No,
no.
It's not placebo at all.
I don't think because we were talking about it's an insanely intense
introspective experience that's not not dissimilar from the DMT trip that you
went on in the,
the fact that it dissolves reality,
it dissolves reality in some sort of strange way and then I haven't experienced
the Ibogaine those trips,
but I have quite a few friends who've done it in.
Every one of them said it sucked like they did not like it,
like it's really harsh,
but the results are spectacular.
Like the results,
like when you get through that you're like,
okay,
I see it all.
It's all mapped out now.
Like what am I doing with my life?
Like what are all these pitfalls that I've set up for myself?
What are all these traps that I've like left in my personality?
What are all these these excuse mechanisms that I have just ready to fucking pop
off and send me to the bar?
What are those things when you see them?
Like they're a like,
like,
like targets.
You see them all around you like really obvious landmines.
It's weird how people have like a lot of us,
we all have some of those,
but for me,
my way of getting out of that is I just asked myself what I really want and I
think that's helpful.
Like when I just go,
what do I really want to do and we'll get good at one thing really interests me.
I think.
You've never been addicted physically to anything?
Now I have.
I so I think we're talking out our ass when it,
when it comes to that.
Yeah.
I never had,
thank God.
I feel,
I feel lucky that I don't have that.
I don't drink much.
I don't,
I never had any of that stuff.
So yeah,
that's the pill one and the heroin one man,
that is a god damn crazy when the coq one,
I've seen them all and they're there.
They're real hard to figure from the outside.
I haven't experienced what the,
the ache in their bones.
Well,
what about how much people drink in this country and have always,
this country has always been a nation of drinkers,
and that's why we get gas.
If you don't give a fuck,
we were drunk.
We make sure it happens,
but it's responsible for a lot of great art too.
You know?
That's one thing that people don't want to admit if course how much fucking
great music was created by drunk people.
I don't know.
I think a lot of great music was start with clearway people who sat in a in
rooms and just played music.
Well,
that's true too.
There was a fucking say that that what destroyed the Haight Ashbury movement at
wonderful psychedelic movement was when,
when musicians went from weed
and psychedelics to heroin and cocaine and the heroin and cocaine was what
actually destroyed a lot of great musicians.
Yeah,
but that's coke.
We're talking about booze.
Yeah.
I think there's been a lot of artists that have used booze,
including writers.
Historically.
There's been a lot of writers that were drunk.
Stephen King,
when he was strong,
his book,
which I already said,
there are a lot of,
yes,
there are a lot of creative people that have substance abuse problems.
He said,
but they happen to be very creative people with substance abuse problems.
He said they were creative and then they,
they had,
they had a problem.
But it's not what made them creative.
That's possible that he's right.
But it's also possible that he's saying that because he's not an addict anymore
and he doesn't want to go back to it.
And so he's made this sort of connection in his mind that it wasn't the alcohol
that allowed him to be so free and creative.
It was his own free creativity that he had in his mind.
And he had a problem.
It is true.
Here's another positive correlation and causation.
There's,
they're not clearly defined in this snow.
Now,
here's another possibility to people that are creative,
um,
and do and have great imaginations and allow themselves to have a great
imagination.
May also be in some,
to some degree,
may be a little self destructive or at least searching for different states.
And so maybe,
maybe you know,
that the kind of person that's imagined enough to write a book like Cujo also
likes putting himself in something other than his sober state total boss as
well.
Totally possible as well.
But I think there's also some thoughts that come to you when you're drunk.
Like I've done some drunk writing,
especially on airplanes.
God,
I'm an idiot.
And when I'm drunk,
well I listen to like music and uh,
have a couple Budweisers and uh,
I'll write and I'll write some stuff that I might not.
Right.
Dude,
I you,
when we were doing the ice house one time,
I was with one of the first times,
it was in a small room and I smoked a bunch of weed and I don't do it.
And I got high doing your podcasts and I drank some scotch because you force me
peer pressure,
I don't think.
And I wrote and I got up on stage and crushed the room with a whole thing.
I kind of in about how I saved a whale.
Now,
I never would've thought about saving a fucking whale,
uh,
without that state.
So I maybe it did open up some channels,
but here you can get back to the booze.
Here's what Oliver delayed delayed.
Oliver Sacks said something incredible.
Do you know the story about Philip Platinum?
I think it's Jason and I think his name's furniture salesman.
1994,
uh,
comes out of a bark.
It's savagely beaten and starts having sort of deep mathematical geometrical
thoughts.
And I've seen,
you know,
he starts drawing these geometric relationships and shapes.
A physicist walks by one day and goes,
do you know what you're doing?
And he said,
no,
I just,
I'm trying to figure out the relationship.
And he goes,
you're drawing high math.
Long story short,
he'd never been interested in math at all.
And 2015,
he is considered a math genius.
He got beaten.
Oliver sacks did a great thing on a guy named Tony.
See auria get struck by lightening.
He's an orthopedic surgeon.
The lightening goes through his cheek,
comes out of his foot.
Tony just want to start right now.
If you're a shitty musician,
don't let someone kick in the head.
I've got it.
Don't do it.
I'm going to be a math genius.
Kick the shit out of me and let me see what happens.
The most creative people are drunk tea,
Tony Crs,
this Tony Syria.
What is this?
This is the article about the Churchill gene,
the Churchill Jean.
Oh a church.
How long has had some in Winston Churchill always had some alcohol under system
up there but,
but,
but listen to this tone,
it's urea who Oliver sacks studied basically get struck by lightning all he can
hear his piano music and becomes a composer and a high level composer and piano
player.
Cause all he wanted to do after that was play the piano and it was never an
instant music.
So the idea is maybe sometimes a certain things that hit happen to your brain
can open pathways and channels and circuitry that wasn't,
that was blocked or wasn't activated before.
In this case it was a beating and lightning.
But there are examples of something traumatic happened to someone's brain where
it opens up an entire new passion and interest in that person and it's,
and that's documented by the late Oliver sacks and a lot of other people.
That's kind of fascinating.
Well,
I think that the mind is some sort of a device and this device realize like the
rest of the body on all the different elements that keep a human being alive.
Human neurotransmitters are flowing around.
There's neurons firing,
there's all these cells that are alive.
I mean the mind is just like this fascinating place.
Now when you introduce things that are psychoactive to the mind,
whether it's caffeine,
whether it's new tropics,
whether it's alcohol,
whether it's teen,
yeah,
sure.
Whether it's marijuana,
there is an effect.
And when that effect happens is there's a cascade of effects.
The effect of marijuana,
there's,
there's a lot of different effects,
but one of them is your creativity absolutely gets kickstart.
Something happens.
You get a weird way of looking at things.
You get a strange altered perspective on things.
Um,
alcohol does the same.
It gives you a strange altered perspective on things,
mate.
You know,
it doesn't introduce your way,
makes you a little louder.
It makes you a little bolder releases inhibitions.
But occasionally someone will write something while on alcohol that is just
brilliant and they'd comes out of this,
don't give a fuck thing that alcohol allows you to look at something from a
different angle.
It's not,
or maybe or maybe drops your inhibitions and you're able to be more yourself in
some instances or how's guilty.
But it's also a possibility that's a combination of those things that they're
not individual,
that this,
you know,
there's,
there's not an either or that they're all a part of like most things in life
that it's,
you know,
it's maybe it quiets down one part of the brain and I'm not mutually exclusive.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I mean,
listen,
man,
I,
we're learning more and more about science,
brain science all the time.
It just shows you not to be too orthodox in their thinking and certainly not too
judgmental in your thinking.
You know what else to that
I think is very important and I've monitored in my own life.
Um,
I don't have a problem with depression,
but I do have days where I feel better and days where I don't feel as good.
And a lot of that is dictated by how I choose to think.
A lot of that is dictated by how I managed my life,
whether I'm happy with things that I'm doing and how I choose to pursue my
thinking,
you know?
And I think there's a certain amount of what that is that makes you feel happy
and makes you feel sad that is manageable.
And I think too,
there's a,
there's definitely a danger and putting it all on a disease and all on a pill.
And for some people it most certainly is a disease,
but there are people that have some wiggle room and their life and they can turn
their life into a much more positive experience for themselves if they just
choose to manage it correctly.
There's,
this is not excluding people that have a legit medical condition and have legit
medical depression and they did some sort of a chemical imbalance.
Not at all,
but I'm saying there was a lot of us that aren't depressed like me that you can
manipulate the way your mind feels.
You can manipulate the way your,
your,
your view of the earth is what you choose to focus on.
Yeah.
You know,
that's 100% true.
You,
you,
you know,
I always think about that.
How you manage what you choose to think about and the perspective that you take.
My God,
they've done they,
you know,
anxiety,
behavioral psychologists.
We used to always say,
you got to get rid of your anxiety.
And now what they say is if you think of anxiety in terms of just your body
getting ready for action as opposed to,
oh no,
this anxiety is going to kill me.
Your blood vessels look very differently.
So the how you view your own anxiety and the attitude you take your,
your blood vessels will either constrict,
which is not good.
But if you look at anxiety,
I,
here I go,
my body's getting ready for this.
I'm getting ready.
Your blood vessels and your heart looks exactly the way it does in moments of
joy and courage.
And that's,
that's fucking great ted talk.
Um,
I again,
I can't remember.
I wish I could tell.
Some people could watch it,
but really interesting how you look,
how you choose to think about your own anxiety has everything to do with how,
whether it's healthy for you or bad for you.
And if you choose to think about anxiety in the right way,
there's a lot of evidence,
measurable evidence based on a study that followed,
I think 30,000 Americans over nine years that suggests that it actually can be
good for you.
That makes sense if you think about it,
because you're,
you're shifting what it is and what it becomes is energy and like this,
like,
oh,
I've got this anxiety,
but you know what?
This is a growth moment.
This is important.
This means we're getting something done.
Something is happening in us.
And and concentrate on least to say that you used to always say,
I like those moments where I'm not sure what's going to happen next.
Yeah,
I do.
Very important.
Fucking into luck.
I'm a little too much called adventure.
It's called adventure adventure.
It is.
That's my nickname on knowing what's going to happen next when I like to do is
run the podcast out to the last five minutes like we're at right now and
wondering when the tapes going to run out.
Why does it last only three hours?
It's the fucking Ustream.
If we were on a,
if we have the balls to switch over to youtube or twitch three hours,
it's enough.
It seems like a good number.
You know people get mad now when I do too.
I did two hours yesterday with Ronda Rousey.
People were complaining they wanted more.
They call me a lazy,
do nothing,
bitch bastards.
They call me do nothing,
bitch.
I don't really read.
I don't read any of my hat.
I don't think any of my comments.
Well,
it's dangerous.
A comic friend of mine was talking shit about me and Brendan and I thought it
was,
who said his name?
Don't know.
But I walked by,
but it was surprising.
He's a young guy.
I like,
and he might,
he might have been misconstrued.
It might've been,
who knows?
It might be sad.
Might not be happy.
Like am I feel bad?
Might not get no laid.
Maybe you uh,
Miss Gender.
Tim with the wrong pronoun.
Try here.
Z ladies,
he's gentleman and Zeros here.
You can call them here.
They're teaching new pronouns.
September 23rd.
Come see me and Joe.
September 22nd,
come see me and Joe.
You guys have September 23rd.
Come see me and Joe at the Hong Kong in eight o'clock and 10 o'clock.
We had an eight o'clock show just now.
Yeah,
but where can they buy the tickets for that?
Do we know?
We haven't even advertised.
Yeah,
just go to the Hong Kong in Hong Kong,
in Hong Kong,
in.com.
The ice hockey tickets are not on sale yet either.
So calm you can buy,
they'll sell out immediately.
And,
uh,
this Friday I'm at the car theater.
If you go into the UFC in Vegas,
um,
at the coffee at her on Friday night with Greg Fitzsimmons and Ian Edwards,
love both of those guys.
Time Fun.
You fucks.
I'm at the San Jose Improv.
September 25,
26,
27,
one of my favorite places ever.
That was a beautiful place.
I've only done it once a while and sit on theater.
It was an old theater theater and they converted it into a comedy club.
It's beautiful.
It's one of the best Improv's and the policeman.
Yeah,
it's awesome.
Awesome.
People can't to.
All right.
You fuckers.
Thank you very much everybody.
Much love.
Love you all.
Bye Bye.
Yeah.